hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm just checking in
on you i'm just checking in on you
seeing how you weeks going
literally just [__] woke up just woke
up and right to work
boo hoo
this is one of these things that you
[__] yell about in your relationship
oh you got a problem with me
huh
i [__] open my eyes and i'm
immediately [__] doing a podcast
and for what
for this right one of those dumb fights
um
i'm on the road again chicka boom chicka
boom boom boom
i'm out here in uh san francisco
i did the punch line two nights ago
and i haven't played there in a in a
while
it was so great to be back at that club
um
just one of the
one of the best comedy clubs of all time
i really missed being at that place so i
had an awesome time
um
i was working there with joe bartnick
who by the way is on his way to canada
today
to perform in montreal at a brand new
comedy club right above uh
stogies
the cigar place um cigar bar
should say instead of cigar place um
let's check him out this weekend
and also was working with bianca chris
davao
um she [__] killed it just a great
night a great hang the whole thing
and then yesterday
um
i was down the gym you know throwing the
weights around trying to keep the dad
brought at bay
uh
of course i forgot i had a [__]
meeting so i had to stop in the middle
of it and then when i was done with the
[__] meeting i decided rather than go
back down and do cardio i was gonna walk
the city because i hadn't been here in a
minute and what a great [__] city
it still is despite the fact all the
silicon valley [__] came in here with
the i created an app money
and i guess drove the real estate
through the [__] roof
um still a great city
i walked along uh
the seaport down there whatever the hell
you call it
and then at some point banged the left
walked up the hill came down the hill
went all the way through chinatown
which was awesome
um
yeah i did all right too there's a
zillion places i wanted to [__] eat
at but instead
i got an apple and some raw almonds oh
jesus but i gotta tell you the second i
ate it then i was fine i was like oh
thank god
thank god i didn't negate my [__]
workout um
and uh the reason i actually came up
here to san francisco was because i
wanted to see that uh motley crue death
leopard poison joan jet show
uh which i did at pac bell the stick
whatever the [__] they oracle
whatever they're calling it every other
year they [__] rename that thing
uh where the [__] happened to my laptop
i don't remember dropping it it's got a
big [__] hack on the side of it
um
so i went to i got there early because
there was no way i was gonna loop uh was
gonna miss joan jet she absolutely
[__] destroyed
and um
i got to stand on the side of the stage
and watch him side of stage stinks by
the way you can't [__] hear anything
it's just the sound slapping back and
forth it's just cool to be standing that
close to them playing but it's way
better out in the house so
i stood on the side of stage for joan
jett absolutely killed her the [__]
band was great the background vocals
were totally on point they sounded
amazing
um
and being an old guy now
i was thinking like joan jett has the
best [__] slot
on the whole lineup
it was like 5 30 and she was done
she could go out to dinner enjoy the
city
she could go back to the hotel room and
just go to sleep
that's like that [__] that's just i
want to do a [__] 4 30 to 5 30
stand-up show and call it a night
i mean dude you could still hit a
[__] game
that would be perfect
the problem is as i say [__] every other
word in my act so that means you go on
after 8 p.m
you have to go on when the sun goes down
and you know all the goody two shoes
have gone to bed
goody two shoes you mean the [__]
smart people
i wonder why it's two shoes
there's something i should go on the
internet and [__] kill three minutes
of my life that'll never get back why is
it goody two shoes
you
know it's always a pair of shoes
you don't just make one or do you
someone's missing a leg maybe you do
i don't [__] know anyway
um then poison came out
and uh
that was just immediately just it was
just so [__] great to see like
i don't know there's a band sounds
different i feel like a pre-internet
band we can just tell that people
learned how to play like listening to
records
and trying to figure it out
and you know you've maybe figured it out
or maybe you figured three quarters of
it out and then you added your [__] to
it or whatever they just totally have
like the uh
you know parents basement garage band
that's one of their lyrics um vibe to
them
and uh
they [__] killed it
absolutely [__] killed it
um i saw on the side of the stage for
for the first couple of songs it was
just really loud and i couldn't hear
anything so i wanted to be out in the
crowd
to see it um
and then motley crew went on
and uh
i don't know it might be the best i've
ever heard mick mars sound
like his tone was [__] unbelievable
tommy lee of course killed it nikki
killed it and vince sounded better than
he sounded forever and um
i'm not going to go into any details or
whatever but i i felt like
they gave the most authentic like if you
missed the 80s here it is
like they just [__] have not
in the greatest way ever just like
they're just [__]
of that
all of this [__] [__] that has
happened since then where everybody's
walking around pretending that they give
a [__] about every cause
it was it was they was just [__] they
were [__] uh they were awesome
and uh
by then i was out in the crowd so i got
to hear their whole set without like
that back slap or anything
and um
they they just
they just [__] murdered man they
[__] murdered and uh
dude tommy lee still just [__] kills
it
still just [__] kills it he doesn't
have like that i slowed down a little
bit vibe
at all
um
just [__] smashing
and um
they started off with uh
oh what's up uh
wild side
which is one of my favorite mother crue
songs to try and play along to
and just watching the guy that came up
with the drum part play it and just play
it so [__] effortlessly cuz
it was just uh
it was really cool and then you know
nikki talked to the crowd at one point
and tommy talked to the crowd and it was
[__] funny and cool and everything
was just awesome
and then um
def leppard i had seen them
at the whiskey so i saw their whole set
and at that point i'm not gonna lie to
you man it was [__] loud and my ears
was where i was just worried about you
know
sitting out there even with my [__]
ear plugs on because i got the tinnitus
in the right ear right
and i was like i already saw them and
i'm tired and i got to get up early to
get on a flight so
i pulled an old man move
and uh i left i know that def leppard
killed the two because i watched i saw
this set like i said when they were in
la getting ready for it
but um
good lord what a [__]
what a lineup what a show i mean if
you're thinking about going to that
thing i can definitely say you should go
to it and you will not feel
anything other than you got your money's
worth man it was [__]
it was [__] awesome and then also to
see him
in um
one of the greatest ballparks
in in in major league you know i was
sitting up there we could see like
mccovey's cove looking at mccovey's cove
and all of that [__]
uh the beautiful ballpark
while just sitting there watching you
know poison motley crew
it was just [__] i was like jesus
christ this is the way to go to a damn
concert
back in the day standing on those
plastic chairs on the floor i'm too
[__] old for that
it was cool though to see there was a
bunch of young kids there
um seeing that they were into that music
and then i was thinking like hoping that
they were playing you know guitar drums
bass or something
um
but anyway you can tell i didn't get
much [__] sleep last night it was
kind of uh you know then i came back and
i was watching all the all the old
[__] music videos but like um in the
best way ever like that music took me
all the way back not in a sad way at all
just thinking like man i went to these
[__] shows
and
uh i remember like
it was just never ending that was the
thing because albums were coming out all
the time in the worcester centrum and
the providence civic center
in the boston garden with the three big
venues
near where i where i lived in
massachusetts and i got i didn't know
how many [__] times i went down to
those things
and i still felt like i didn't see
enough bands
and the first time you go you're all
sitting there like going like oh [__] am
i gonna get [__] up here somebody
gonna stab me you know you hear all
these crazy uh
stories about going to concerts and then
uh
you know you get a couple under your
belt
you're comfortable
and uh
yeah i was the 80s you just got
completely [__] up you went to the
show and then you drove home
somebody else did it was that aspect of
it was stupid but that's basically what
happened and as you got closer and
closer to the venue
there was just more long-haired people
uh
more metal kids
just open containers weed smoke coming
out of cars it was [__] nuts
like
people standing on the side of the road
pissing
as you got closer and closer to the
venue it was [__]
it was [__]
all the [__]
all the heavy metal chicks
just [__] dressed like hookers and
[__] i mean i was just [__] wild it
was really wild like i'm sure like you
know
whatever the hell kids do nowadays i'm
going to sound over they go to [__]
raves to go to some dj thing and
everybody
does molly you're [__] rubbing up
against each other like a bunch of
straight dogs
i don't know
every generation does it a little bit
different but it's kind of the same
thing though right
a bunch of kids head into a venue
everybody getting [__] up
and then whatever that music is is just
permanently stamped
in your [__] soul for the rest of
your life like as much as i try
you know and stay up on music which i
obviously
am not like um
you know i just found out about that bad
bunny like i saw uh
some venue i was doing bad bunny was
either advertised there or was going to
be
going somewhere in the city or what i
was like bad bunny what the [__] is bad
bunnies i was sitting there
looking at that and just watching like
you know like
dude plays like huge venues you're
watching just like 40 000 people going
nuts and it's just like
i had never even heard of the person
just like jesus christ there's no after
a while there's just no way to keep up
but um even the amount that i did try to
keep up
like i hung in there i think
probably
until the early 2000s
and then there's this whole
like
i don't know what there's like a 10-year
period there
where i just stopped trying and then i
by the time i came back it was just kind
of a wrap
but um
during that whole time of like
like
somewhere between
like panic at the disco remember those
bands
like the strokes
um
there was another one i can't remember
their names
and i was just thinking when i was at
that show going like jesus christ those
some of those [__] people
they're 20 years in
like what the [__]
what the hell billy nostalgic here um
anyway so that show
that uh joan jet poison motley crew and
uh
def leppard show
uh i think their last u.s stop
is not tonight it's tomorrow in las
vegas
and i was talking to some of the um
guys uh who were on that tour and they
were saying how
they take like
the rest of the year off and then like
in january and february it starts back
up again
going all through south america and
anything so
and everything that's [__] amazing
i'm
psyched for all those bands that they're
all going to go out and make some
[__]
great money and all of that [__] that
they can still do it this far into their
careers is uh pretty goddamn cool
so anyways if you get a chance if you're
somehow anywhere near vegas i know this
is a short notice um
i hope you can catch the show because
it's just a [__] great
great show great everybody just a
different vibe but everyone was having
like fun like when we went up on stage i
feel like such an [__] i was so busy
like i want to see all the drum kits you
know
i guess i walked right by joan jett
who's literally standing there with a
guitar
and she looked at bartnik and she goes
hey man she goes have fun today or
something like that and i was just
thinking like that's kind of like what
it was all about
before um
it got like all [__] sad and morose
when like the the grunge guys came in
i mean granted it was probably an
emotion that was completely ignored in
the 80s sadness
[Laughter]
i would blame the cocaine
um yeah everybody was up
it was the up 80s and you know it's
funny i remember a long time ago i saw
in like vh1
one of the members of salt and pepper
was talking about
doing you know doing their shows in the
80s and the lineups they were on
and she was just like yeah you know back
then it was there wasn't all of this you
know uh beefing between you know mcs and
everything she was like it was just fun
we were just out there having fun
and um
i'm trying to think i wonder why that
was
it was like why the 80s was just like
this like
awesome and ridiculous level of fun
and then the 90s came in like the
[__] hangover
like hey just to remind you
you know
[Laughter]
i think that's why it took me so long
or i was so late to like like i always
liked allison chains and i always liked
soundgarden
but like um
[Music]
you know it took me a minute with
nirvana because nirvana knocked all my
favorite bands i've talked about this a
million times off of the top
10 on mtv back when that was a thing
and uh
just going from all these fun songs to
their [__] i was just like
my god god what what who brought the
[__] wet blanket in here like what's
going on
i wish i was like you
easily amused it's like jesus christ man
i have a [__] beer
[Laughter]
you know put on some fingerless gloves
and go drive a camaro like what is the
[__] problem
little did i realize
that i was in a walking depression that
was going to last for another 15 [__]
years that's what's so funny to me
like now i go back and i listen to
nirvana i'm like this [__] band is
amazing
um
[Music]
and i love
i love never mind in uh in utero and uh
i don't know bleach i never really got
into that i can't
i didn't get into that one but like now
i get it it's like oh yeah all right
uh
i guess they were making some valid
points about the human experience
i just probably wasn't ready to hear it
yeah it was a way yeah i think that's
what it was because the ban it came out
and i was like
i was like 23 when it came out which is
a weird [__] age
you know
you turned 21 oh [__] i'm legal it's
like a drink now right and then you turn
22 and you're like whoa
well there's nothing you know got my
driver's license i could drink
i should have graduated college i'm
still a freshman
and with 23 hit i remember i was just
like
oh this isn't gonna stop like this is
just like
i'm gonna be all these [__] ages i'm
gonna hopefully you know god will i
didn't look at it like god willing back
then but you were just
like i just remember like uh
like 24 was a [__]
when i was like in my teens 24 was just
like wow man
that guy should be like married with
kids 25 26 27 was just like what the
[__]
um
and now what's funny is now i'm 54 and
when i i talked to uh
you know people in their 30s like
i mean i know they're adults but they're
like kids to me because it's just such a
big
still like a huge gap
um
you know what i mean like if you're
talking about day to day it's
like once you're talking to somebody
younger than you
like the gap of [__] that you can talk
about just gets smaller and smaller the
bigger the the age gap gets you know
unless it's like your kids because then
you just like
you know fully invested
wanting to know what's going on in their
lives and all of that [__]
um
which by the way i got such a [__]
great relationship with my daughter i'm
so happy about that
you know every night when i put her to
bed it used to be i came home i told
this
it's all [__] running together but
you know what i'm not going to be busy
in a month from now
it's going to slow down hopefully
um
started off i would i would uh read her
stories
and then we graduated to we had to sing
the songs from the disney pixar movies
and act them all out and now it's uh
you know i have to sit there and we have
to talk
you know she lays in bed and i sit there
and we talk for like
you know 20 25 minutes every night
before she goes to sleep
and uh
she tells me all the [__] you know
all these freaking toys that she wants
because she watches that that goddamn
ryan
and all the kid does is unbox toys and
all of that stuff and every day it's
like you know dad
can you go to target and get me the ryan
sneakers
uh blah blah blah and i just look at her
and she starts laughing it's like i'm
not buying you
all of this stuff she watches that and
then she watches that um
vlady and nikki
which are two
like uh two kids from like
eastern europe or some [__]
just playing with toys i don't know it's
weird
kids like watch other kids play like
video games
you know i mean i guess i watch other
men play sports
but the thing is i can't do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a kid playing a video game it's
just like
you could do that i guess maybe you're
watching the kid play the video game so
you learn how to get better at it
i don't know whatever it's whatever it's
what they're into if i was that age i
guess i would be doing the same [__]
um oh billy's looking back on this
podcast
he's [__] oh bill's looking back
um
anyway so uh
what a great time thank you to molly at
the punch line and everybody i i had
such a great time doing that and
uh
um
and and then going to the show was just
[__]
it was just amazing man i'm so glad i
did that
because when it came by sophie stadium
of course
in the city i live in i wasn't in town
surprise surprise
so um
i just picked the next closest city
because people go hey what are you doing
up here i'm like uh i'm up here to see
the show
[Laughter]
what the [__] i'm doing here all right
where the hell is my goddamn
let's read the advertisement here that's
not the one
there it is oh look who it is everyone
policy genius
why get life insurance
um we pay hundreds of dollars per year
to protect our homes our cars even our
phones but too many of us aren't taking
steps to protect our family's finances
why get covered now inflation is driving
up prices for just about everything
lately but life insurance
you know i really hope if trump gets
elected again and he has another [__]
insurrection he sends them to the right
[__] building this time
but life insurance rates are actually
down from this time last year and since
life insurance typically gets more
expensive as you age that means
now is a great time to buy
policy genius is an insurance
marketplace
that makes it easy to compare quotes
from top companies like aig and
prudential in one place to find your
lowest price on life insurance you could
save fifty percent or more on life
insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius options start at just
seventeen dollars per month for five
five hundred thousand dollars of
coverage just click the link in the
description or head to policygenius.com
to get personalized quotes in minutes
and find the right policy for your needs
um
the license agents at policy genius work
for you not the insurance company
they're on hand through the entire
process to help you understand your
options so you can make decisions with
confidence head to policygenius.com
that's p o l i c y genius g e n
g-e-n-i-u-s
if you're like me and i always spell it
wrong to get your free life insurance
quotes and see how much you could save
all right
anyway
uh i'm off to one of my favorite cities
in the country tulsa oklahoma i always
tell you
all right three underrated cities
tulsa oklahoma
milwaukee wisconsin chattanooga
tennessee
all right and there's a whole bunch more
once off those offshoots i also went to
one
in um
where the hell was i i was in north
carolina
i actually forget
i was in the western part of the state
where i was right near the appalachian
mountains
let's see here north carolina
see if we get a map going here
oh billy map face
asheville
i did a gig in asheville what a
beautiful beautiful [__] city
perfect size and then you had all that
mountains and [__]
people up there with them stills making
some moonshine so everybody get [__]
up on the way to the joan jett poison
molly crew def leppard show
um
you guys know i got that i got my closet
redneck
know
i like [__] pickup trucks and i uh i
think guns are cool
i don't know [__] about them and i'm
terrified of them because i didn't grow
up around them and i'm not gonna be that
person that shoots themselves in the
[__] foot
literally
i'm not doing that i ain't going out
like that
who [__] you think you're talking to
um
if i were to get a gun though i would
definitely get a [__] revolver
i like those better
you know what i mean
i don't get these guns with the clips
it's like how many [__]
bullets do you need to hit what the [__]
you're shooting at
like how many people do you think are
coming in to attack you
i'm just doing this to get the gun
people to write in
bill i got to tell you something
actually hitting a target with the gun
is a lot harder than you think
especially if it's moving and we haven't
even taken into effect your nerves at
that point when your life is on the line
okay i mean i'm just [__] with you i
remember club soda kenny was telling me
that there was cops the first time they
pulled their revolver they were so
[__] scared by the time they brought
it level at the target they were already
empty
like they they shot the
first six
you know one right next to their foot a
one about a f the second shot about a
foot in front of it you get the idea all
the way up and by the time they come up
it's like click click click
now here's my question why haven't they
ever showed that in a movie
because you know what it would happen so
fast people wouldn't understand it
um
if they ever make a comedy about cops
which they have
right
reno911
i guess they didn't really pull their
guns on that [__] i don't [__] know
um anyway but uh
watching that show all that's making me
want to do is go play some [__] drums
and um
i don't know it was the perfect night
underrated you know [__]
just going oh wait i had i had a [__]
overrated
i won't be able to remember i remember
the second i [__] hang this thing up
[__] it was a good one i should have
wrote it down i can start writing [__]
down
um
god damn it
anyway uh
i'm looking forward to coming out to
tulsa
just a great food scene great art scene
uh the one and only time i've ever seen
a bald eagle
was when i was out there and no i wasn't
looking in the [__] mirror you
[__]
um
all right that's it um that's the
podcast and we're gonna have a bonus
episode after some music
um picked out
by the always wonderful andrew themless
and then we'll have a bonus episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday
monday morning podcast um
i hope you can make it to vegas to catch
that show if you didn't i hope you saw
it when it came by uh
when it came by your city what a [__]
great time that was
just a great time um all right that's it
i'll talk to yous later
what's up everybody we are back
football is back and our partners at bet
mgm are back for the 2022 nfl season we
will be using once again the best app
out there using the bet mgm lines to
make all of our picks and we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up for bet
mgm yet same bonus code as last season
guys use bonus code burr very easy bur
and you will get 100
risk free bet up to a thousand
dollars dude first wager here's how it
works you download the bet mgm app you
sign up using bonus code b-u-r-r that's
burr b-u-r-r deposit at least ten
dollars and place your first wager on
any game you'll receive up to a thousand
dollars in free bets
um in in your bets if your bet loses
just make sure you use bonus code when
you sign up so you're basically getting
a thousand dollars to gamble with right
am i saying that right andrew
yeah i mean it's a joke dude it's a it's
an absolute joke to start off this
season that way all right so before we
get into our week one picks our four
picks each which is very exciting we're
gonna do something where we have a
little fun and we pick our super bowl
picks we're just you know shooting the
[__] obviously shot in the dark but bill
who do you like gun to your head before
the first kickoff of the season nobody's
brain no-brainer
what are you like a no-brainer i like
the buffalo bills
playing in the easy afc east
there's all those [__] juggernaut
quarterbacks in the afc west [__]
slamming into each other and doing all
of that [__] out there dealing with all
of that crap the bills are gonna cruise
through the afc east i believe and i
think that they uh adam von miller and
all of these other [__] guys i think
that they go to the super bowl
and you know the rams
have found this clever way paul of
getting around the [__] salary cap
where they can they can give out 400
million dollars worth of contracts to
five [__] guys but it doesn't count
because we gave you cash here above all
of this [__] that if the patriots did it
they'd be getting a ton of [__] so
they've spent so much [__] money like
all la teams whenever they win a [__]
title
um
i think that they're gonna get back
there because they've spent so much
[__] money
on all of these people
uh i think that they get back there
there's nobody really i don't know
49ers
i can't remember the name of their
[__] quarterback dude well they're
they're there
is jimmy g there now or they got
something else they renegotiated to have
jimmy g but they got this young kid trey
lance that's why i'm gonna change one of
my picks but bill has the bills and the
rams in the big one in arizona at the
end of the year those are great i feel
like seattle's gonna be trying to figure
out who the [__] they are now that they
have a new quarterback i think the 49ers
don't have a qb
and the rams have figured out a way
around the salary cap and they [__]
signed everybody but jesus you know
probably sign [__] leonard
um
yeah i mean i think seattle's done
unless sneaky pete pulls something over
somebody's eyes which always known to do
sneaky pete is a good coach he's a good
coach and he is not above bending the
rules uh he does it in seattle and runs
out the back door at [__] ufc so no
one really it never really stuck
um
his big thing is he never pissed off jim
irsay
[Laughter]
um
all right my super bowl picks i'm just
gonna make a change i know we talked
about this before i'm sticking with the
chargers i think the chargers are gonna
not only go to the super bowl i think
they're gonna win it with justin herbert
but instead of the 49ers just because i
don't really like this i'm going to jump
off that because i don't like this trey
lance
jimmy g coming back which means he's
going to be hanging over his shoulder
the whole like you know what i mean i
think if trey lance has a like bad week
couple weeks jimmy g's gonna be lurking
that's never worked out from what i've
seen very very seldom except with the
philadelphia eagles and nick foles and
you know weird [__] like that i don't
see that happening
you're gonna laugh bill i'm going back
i'll go that's crazy i said so it's like
it's lunacy
i'm gonna go back to the packers man i'm
gonna go back to aaron rodgers in the
back i know i know it's it's
it's
it's i know it's it's not
i know when are you gonna break up with
this stripper i know jesus christ
every year they give you a lap dance and
you're back to the atm machine it's it's
it's like saying the knicks are gonna
have a good year it's actually lunacy
but when i look at the nfc i don't know
if i believe in the vikings and aaron
rodgers is still aaron rodgers and they
still did win 13 games last year
i'm gonna say the chargers beat the
packers in the super bowl this year i
think this is justin herbert's [__]
year so there you go those are okay
right now if that [__] happens that's
gonna be one of the great picks of all
time because that none of that was even
remotely on my radar
um i mean i know the packers of the
packers with aaron rodgers and [__] i
get that but uh
san diego charges dude that's a strong
[__] that's a bold bold prediction i
don't think i didn't think either one of
the things that i said was bold i just
went with the two [__] i don't know
the bill's the favorite in the east the
build the bills are great and i think
what doing what you said we're getting
von miller and and coming back healthy
and dude josh allen is he's like [__]
john wayne he's he's huge he's like
roethlisberger these guys you know no
they're great dude they're and they're
well coached i like i like our super
bowl picks so there you have it guys let
us know right into andrew without being
a dick and say who you like and maybe
we'll do a couple that i don't know but
now it's time
now it's time week one
i think can i tell you something in the
afc's it's gonna be [__] joe burrow
and josh allen and there's gonna be a
great [__] rivalry that's gonna
develop between
those level of disrespect you showed
justin herbert look at the kid's numbers
there's i mean you ha i mean the kid is
great
you don't like him i mean no i'm not
saying i'm not saying i don't like him
i'm not saying that i just don't think
he has the defense
oh okay well i could see that i mean i i
think he could see that i think he's
like every [__] san diego quarterback
i've been watching since dan fought
where he's got to score [__] a lot of
points
to win and that does well
during the regular season then when you
get to the playoffs you eventually run
into a shutdown defense and then your
defense has to hold them which they
haven't been doing all year and it all
goes out the window
hey man
touche i get it i get it all right here
we go bill you're getting the first pick
this year because i believe i had the
first pick last year
so
you
uh
are
we're off and running here week one guys
bill gets four picks i get four picks
bill before we get started do you want
to change the rule that we had last year
where if we tie it's it's not it's not a
half a game where you just have to beat
the spread or do you want to keep it the
way it was last year
um
like in other words if it's ten points
and it ends up ten points well you know
something i like the tie if you get the
tie and you're like three you know
you're whatever you you
two one and one i like it because i
think it it adds a funny element to it
okay all right i think because it throws
like a wrench into it
okay i'm not the best at math but i feel
like if it's just win or loss win a loss
win a loss then if someone starts
running away with it it gets boring but
like if you get a couple of ties in
there
or i do and it keeps me hanging around
he's hanging around i think that could
be fun
all right so there you have it guys if
the game is seven and we pick it and it
ends ends up seven we get half a we get
a half a half a win
uh
all right
you are on the clock
um all right right out of the gate
um it's a big number but i'm gonna take
the ravens minus seven over the hapless
jets
ooh
that's a that's a that's a dub
that's a dub i i'm doing it you know
what i'm doing i'm gonna do it just
because i actually really believe it i'm
actually not doing it because they're my
team i believe it
i believe
that saquon barkley being healthy
and the new
tackle we got from alabama
and we're on the road as dogs in
tennessee
i believe i don't know if the giants
pull off the win but i don't think
they're gonna lose by by seven so i'm
gonna take my new york football giants
getting six in tennessee
behind a better line and a healthy
saquon barkley
plus six andrew
plus six andrew put it on the board
um
all right i'm gonna take uh
this feels so good doesn't it
i just hope i have time to watch the
games ah
i'm gonna take next i am going to take
i don't know i'm gonna take a dog here
i'm gonna take the cardinals getting six
points
at home getting six points at home
playing the chiefs i feel like the
chiefs historically start slow they lost
tyreek hill
to free agency i think you know i'm not
saying the chiefs are going to be bad
this year i think they might be a little
you know two and two to start or
whatever
and um
i don't know i think uh
kyla murray is gonna be a problem as he
always is they still got j.j watts is
back i believe right he's healthy after
uh last season i think i don't know
i didn't have time to look at any of
this
oh hang on a second that could be that
could be
is it club soda kenny
one of the silliest men ever ah paul i
got the espresso here
you know there's a game that i
oh wait it's your pick
[__] terrible
i don't people understand that if you
burn the beans that's not a good [__]
espresso all right i know you took the
oh no i'm sorry you took the cardinals i
took kyla murray
all right well
this is a tough one dude this is a tough
week one is tough you know you don't
know anything here just you know just
let it fly paul
sling it just let it fly
all right um
i'm not i know what everybody's thinking
i'm gonna do pick the packers i know i
know
um
let's take tom brady in the bucks
at dallas i like how you said that i'm
gonna take tom brady in the box
at dallas
on uh what is that is that sunday night
football the first sunday night football
minus two and a half
given two
um
all right now this is where it gets hard
because i don't know anything about
anybody i don't know why paul but i'm
going to take the charges because i want
to watch the game
against the raiders oof that was my next
pick that's a good one three and a half
um
[Music]
i like that number
i think this is i am so excited to watch
the afc west this year i can't even tell
you dude
um
i love both of those teams last year i
watched their second game on mushrooms
and it was one of the great things i've
ever done in my life
dude watching a game where everybody's
just airing it out on mushrooms i'm
telling you man
sounds fun
all right i'm gonna take um
i'm gonna take the washington commanders
at home
uh giving two and a half points today i
like that game
jacksonville jaguars
i'd like that there was something about
that game that stuck out
i'm gonna yeah the jags have they got
the uh the kid from clemson right they
got the kid from clemson they started to
play a little better towards the end of
last year but i don't know
i don't know the commanders uh
got a decent defense if they're healthy
i'm i'm gonna take them uh i'm gonna
take that minus two and a half andrew i
gotta tell you that name's starting to
get that's starting to work for me oh i
like it i like the commanders a lot
commanders commanders and
commander-in-chief
yeah just you know
makes you want to share again
a little arrogant it's better than the
guardians cleveland guardians man that
just sounds like it's some [__]
outsourced security team
um i'll tell you the game of the [__]
week though is going to be the broncos
going back to uh russell wilson going
back to seattle his first [__] game
on monday night football i mean tell me
just tell me that the nfl doesn't know
how like the nfl like i mean the nba
should learn from these guys
[__] jerk-offs um
all right so here's the last one paul i
don't want to step on your toes here i
don't even know why i looked at this
game but
i just don't believe in the vikings dude
i'm gonna take the packers minus one and
a half i'm sorry
i know you were looking at that game i
don't know i don't mean to get a lap
dance from you [__]
listen man you snooze you lose dude
whoever doesn't say it that's it
um
i i'm looking at this game here and this
one i don't know man
paul it's the nfl season
i'm gonna
now this is paulie going back to his old
ways oh paul i can't lay off a favorite
i'm gonna take the road favorite
indianapolis cults
given seven
to the hapless
hapless
uh houston texans i'm taking jonathan
taylor running the ball like an absolute
animal he's got a good offensive line i
think they could win that game or at
least push that game so i'm gonna take
the colts minus seven at houston
and who do they uh who's who's the cults
have as a qb they signed somebody didn't
they wait it's not wence anymore
no it's not wetz anymore is it
dude i love the coats last year that was
my team i rode with those guys they
always scored they scored [__] points
but they they went with somebody else
didn't they
yeah who the [__] is it who the [__] did
these [__] guys take
just hold on a second
is it gary huff
no colt's qb hold on
is it gary hoga boom
oh no it's maddie ice matt ryan
what
they got matt ryan from the falcons ah
[__] dude that's a great pick that's you
know what paul
i don't know i don't want to jinx it
yeah don't jinx me that's a lock
uh you know what seven i feel like some
wings
seven's a perfect number though hey how
about maddie ice finally getting out of
the bermuda triangle that is the [__]
atlanta falcons
and maybe he can score a bunch of
[__] points and win a game and he's
got an animal for a running back and a
good offensive line so you got a
receiver out there too
now that yeah jones went uh where the
hell did julio jones go julio jones went
to the bucks with brady
oh
helps to know these things when you're
picking games
oh this is my on the road breakfast
double espresso and an orange this is
what i do
i don't think it's doing anything for me
and my physique but it uh it's fun
so andrew have we done what three games
each
no that picked four wait that's it
that's it
all right so i got the giants the
commanders
i got the giants the commanders the
cults the puppets in orange while
they're doing a podcast i got the [__]
all over my fingers okay there we go
there are our picks
so there you go everybody if you're
following the anything better oh look at
look at andrew by the way let's let's
let's take a second to look at our
producer what our producer andrew
females put together here got some
illustrations this year we didn't even
have these last year last year it was
done on paper so here you go everybody
[__]
yes you want professional yeah look at
this if you want to follow the anything
better bets on bet mgm
bill has the ravens minus seven the
cardinals plus six the chargers minus
three and a half and the packers minus
one and a half and i have the colts
minus seven the commanders minus two and
a half the giants plus six and the
buccaneers minus two and a half for week
one and what do you see there paul
what do you see there if you look at
both of our picks what is the similarity
um a little mixture of favorites and
dogs not all one
three favorites and one dog
okay yeah yeah
but the exact same thing paul yeah but
the packers is almost like a pickum it's
close it's like you know you're never
going to win by two really rare saying
paul like mines you know
like mines let's see i mean look i like
my second like paul
um
you love my colts pick and i love your
chargers pick well i love you
um now it's time for bill guess what
time it is for oh let the monday night
special
win some money for you
we did it for
special monday night special our monday
night special this week
features the denver broncos with the
newly acquired russell wilson going into
sneaky pete's house
i'll tell you right if you don't watch
that game the woman in your life does
not let you watch that game you need to
get out of that relationship
no i don't give a [__] if it's her
birthday
okay
russell wilson is going back
into seattle to drop it down the bucket
on his old team
to be a fly on the wall in sneaky pete's
office before this game would be
something i'd love to do sneaky pete's
wife is making no eye contact this week
no eye contact
your grandfather's under a little bit of
stress this week
shut up marge
[Laughter]
carol has not wanted to win a game this
bad since that patriots super bowl
oh dude pete carroll is this has been i
mean he's obsessing
he's obsessing he's pacing
you know what time a guy is [__]
aging great he's a 70 year old man
all right paul
like that's so funny
yeah dude this is he's he's towards the
end here and he's got to show these
[__] guys
okay he doesn't want the buzzards
circling over his head paul that's the
new thing who's going to be the first
coach of the year to have the buzzards
circling over his [__] head
who's going to be the first coach
putting his house up on the market
uh i don't know man if sneaky pete wins
only four or five games he could be
the buzzards could be the buzzers can no
no no
no pete pete
he's earned three bad seasons
yes carol dude pete carroll's a hall of
fame coach man
he's won at all levels questionably how
he's won it but you know he's one
yeah
uh hey let's see he's ran out the back
door okay hey he's dipping into the
church basket there okay
[Music]
that's perfect
all right so
andrew for the for this year for the one
game parlay the the monday night special
we can do an under over we could do a
a player to get a touchdown or or two
right or right a player to get yeah
yeah player to score and then um and
under over might be the espresso talking
but i think that game's gonna be bananas
okay i i do you think it goes over paul
what's the under over there andrew
it's uh totals 44 and a half of course
it is of course great number
one
oh andrew our producer likes under you
know i was thinking i was thinking
that's a lot of points for denver's got
a pretty good defense that place gets
really loud fake loud
i don't know i don't know man let's go
under them
all right
so let's take we take the broncos
dude i'm like that guy in the back seat
on a road trip he doesn't give a [__]
right what are you over hunter i don't
give a [__]
we're going to the game i got a six-pack
whatever you want to do i hop denny's
same [__] thing i don't give a [__]
my phone off i got some [__] a couple
yards on the game hey bill cracker brown
just don't pass it just don't pass it oh
that hurts good old-fashioned trucker
food that [__] piece of [__] [__]
goulash
um oh my god that dude trucker was sh i
had to take a dump and that there was a
trucker in there i swear to go with duck
boots on just sitting on the [__]
throne
dude there were some goulash they were
serving goulash at a mobile
dude here's another thing too there is
no way if you were raised right that you
can walk into a public bathroom and sit
on on the other side of somebody who's
already taken a [__] if you have to take
a dump there's got to be nobody in there
a hundred percent 100 has to be nobody
in there unless you're in an airport and
there's a connecting flight and there's
like 30 salesmen lining up and you don't
know who's doing what it's just it's
just
literally paul it's literally a [__]
show unless you have a stomach flu or
virus that's the only exception
i'll do it i'll miss a flight and take a
train
before i [__] next to a [__] stranger
so are we gonna say
are we gonna say russell wilson runs for
one or throws one can we do that andrew
yeah it'll just be that's yeah scores a
touchdown so that'll be considered his
sport so if we say score is a touchdown
it's either or no yeah yeah
what do you think bill russell wilson
you know what i'm thinking i've watched
so much u.s open this week andrew
femilis looks like a tennis pro
he does it looks like he's advanced to
the round of 16. by the way shout out to
serena williams
um i ended up watching that her last
match there i don't know if she's gonna
retire or whatever but uh
it was [__] uh what a what a run man
what a [__] run and then you walk off
paul and you know what the whole event
continues
and more greats coming along
won't be as great as her but like that's
what i was kind of getting was she was
walking off and everybody's waving
i don't like her i never liked her i
love her sister venus i think her sister
venus is a class act i'm not a serena
guy what got me was the thing with that
when that asian tennis player
cried and apologized for winning cause
serena didn't like the calls and i was
just like taking her moment i'm not a
serena guy i'm a venus williams guy
you know but god bless her she's one of
the best what can you say
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know i mean i gotta call it you know
not my favorite you know hey you know
what that reminded me of it reminded me
of bill o'reilly's tribute to [__]
uh george carlin when he died
what did he do now he goes that tribute
and there was just an interview with him
going you swear a lot
why don't you swear so much that's like
it's just him basically
[__] on or criticizing him was his
tribute to george carlin was carlin on
carlin went on his thing and he was
asking him why he cursed so much and all
that
um dude i'll actually tell you this
about tennis paul i actually i texted
this to you i think tennis is more
difficult than golf because it's the
same thing that you golfers talk about
where there's that mental thing you're
gonna address the ball you have all this
time to think and when you [__] up and
your game gets bad and it's just dude i
was watching this dude playing was it
nadal the guy always wins the french
open
rafael nadal yeah yeah so i was watching
playing dude this guy mopped the [__]
floor with him in the first set broke
him twice or something like that
the guy he he could play
at nadal's level
all right but nadel every time he made a
point he'd [__] go like that like i'm
turning it around turning around and he
still lost the first set the next set
uh they're going to the second set he
breaks the guy and the guy's whole game
falls apart
and you're just looking at like what is
the difference between the two of them
in that moment
is that when this other guy was kicking
his [__] ass nadel doesn't he doesn't
[__] doesn't change doesn't waver and
it's the same thing on the golf course
so i feel like it's the same mental game
because it is just you except you got to
hit a ball that can be going upwards of
130 miles an hour rather than it's
sticking up on a tee and you got to make
a quick decision too yeah and i and i
think if there was um
if there was more doctors out there when
[__] old fat guys were walking in
going up you know you're gonna have a
heart attack take up a sport if more of
them said take up tennis i think you'd
get more respect for how tough it is
it's just such a physically demanding
game and mentally
demanding game i i actually uh i don't
know i've been having a really good time
watching
watching the uh the us open there i said
it paul i think it's i think it's harder
than golf
um
what uh so what are we doing monday
night special we're gonna take um
we're gonna take uh
oh my 20 minute point you just go right
back to what we were talking about no no
no no no i i
i love you i'll tell you this dude i am
a serena guy and i think she was [__]
amazing and all the [__] she had to
deal with
going through i remember that time she
did like the [__] [__] walk and all
that and then fox news was like she
throwing up gang signs and blah blah
it's like she's from that neighborhood
she's having a good time she's having a
good time can you just [__] let her
have a good time i thought she was he
was amazing and just watching her out
there man
my mother-in-law's going she looks tired
i'm like she's a 41 year old mother
she's probably exhausted yeah
at the highest [__] level venus
retired too i think like two years ago i
think they're both yeah they're both i
think they both have multiple kids i
think
uh um no cena has one kid i don't think
venus has any kids but just like
you know
if will smith didn't do what he did at
the oscars more people would have saw
that movie
you want to talk about screwing the
pooch
i mean jesus christ dude it was like it
was his night he was gonna win the [__]
no dude i like i like your comparison of
golf and tennis that's actually a cool
argument because in tennis you do have
to have different shots you have to do
it at the sp at a split second the level
of speed golf you could kind of line up
and after doing it a bunch you it's kind
of the same shot we're in tennis you got
to go back and that's a good argument i
like that competition it's also that
thing where it's all on you
everybody's watching it's the same thing
we have to shut the [__] up when
everybody's playing
you know those are the two sports like
they're gonna hit the ball it's the same
[__] thing
and then like dude all the mental [__]
of that like when
you're about to get broken right in your
servant and that first one goes into the
net and then you see that guy creeping
up past the baseline
yeah you gotta be like uh do i come with
the gas or i go safe here and it's just
all of that [__] that they do yeah i
mean
i i think it's it's uh that just
reminded me there was a youtube clip of
this guy about to drive and it's all
quiet his buddy's behind him and his
buddy's leg just starts moving to the
right and he's waiting for the back
swing and right when the guy backs
his buddy just farted so long
and the ball just shot to the ring
and everybody just started laughing um
all right
monday night special we're taking the
are we taking the broncos or we do you
want to take the seahawks what's the
line is it is it six and a half seven
six and a half six and a half dogs at
home
six and a half dogs at home sneaky pete
sneaky pete's getting six and a half
home and you think he's not using that
as motivation
that's straight up disrespect who's that
quarterback though but russell doesn't
like him right quarterback
uh gino's still running like a 440 dude
geno smith is their quarterback i think
we got to take the broncos dude gino
smith has been a backup russell wilson's
coming in a little [__] i i think we
go broncos
how loud is that place going to be every
time he walks up under center paul
i know they'll give him an ovation too
there'll be no booth like he'll feel
good too oh he didn't he took the
[__] money
he wanted out he asked out they're gonna
be [__] pissed
uh dude he gave him a super bowl i mean
he gave him good years
dude they don't give a [__]
they're a bunch of rained on white
people they're miserable
[Laughter]
dude we boot tom brady i know it's
ridiculous it wasn't ridiculous we gave
him an ovation and then when he ran
under center it was just like hey [__]
you you're on the other team
no but they gave him an ovation that i
that you know they gave innovation i
think that that's what's i think he gets
the ovation
and then and i'm not talking guitars
andrew he gets an ovation
a little nod there uh and then he comes
out and then they boom but i'm gonna
tell you this right now dude i russell
wilson for the longest time has been my
favorite quarterback in the nfl just he
just throws the best deep ball in the
[__] game he actually saw such a good
deep ball what he calls it dropping it
down the bucket is now part of like the
sports
you know whatever
not on acronyms whatever expressions
nobody does it better than that guy
right now the deep ball
i think i don't know anything about the
broncos i think i'm overly excited for
this game and i think i just had a
double espresso so i am gonna go
i'm going with the broncos i agree dude
they got a good defense and geno smith
is not a starting quarterback he's
proven that everywhere
and russell's coming back i like the
broncos i like the under and what can we
pick russell to get for more money can
we pick them to get two or it has to be
one
okay
keep them happy yeah
they had bet mgm they they saw what we
were doing with the monday night special
so now they have all these [__] rules
here we want we want you guys some money
yeah it was like when they wouldn't let
wilt dunk paul
we're on the same level this is the
gambling version of that yeah keep it to
what color the jersey's gonna you know
just all safe [__] all right so there
you go no wait no so wait we can we pick
one other thing or no
it's it's three
three things so we put we picked the
under we picked uh
the broncos yep and russell to have a
touchdown
i was gonna say he's gonna throw for two
because i feel like i said but i feel
like gino's not gonna move the ball that
defense is gonna get tired you know what
we'll do this see if see if we can do
russell gets two touchdowns for better
odds and if not we'll just do one can we
do that yep and when you go they go to
the landing page they'll see what the
final bet was so when you go when you go
to the page if you ride with our monday
night special you'll see if it is one or
two touchdowns but we're gonna take the
under we're gonna take the broncos and
we're going to take sneaky pete to get
off to invest i hope he makes some
people some [__] money
again this year
wow look at bill andrew right after a
double espresso he looks like he's ready
to go to a tailgate i love it i love it
no this is my this is the only thing
keeping me going out here paul paul i am
[__] i'm bone on bone out here
mentally
i can't even go to the [__]
[__]
dude i can't [__] with a double espresso
do i be [__] jittery i don't know how
you you're handling it well did i be
able to i could drink a
yeah i could drink a pot of it i could
[__] i could literally
go in and get interrogated by cops and
say i have no idea paul versi has been
an upstanding italian american since
i've met
oh by the way dude i finally watched
that um
that that uh that documentary on the uh
the the the
the trashers the the hockey team the the
the sanitation guy i got dude 15 minutes
from my house
15 minutes he was the real life guy like
joe pesci from casino where what i loved
about his character was is all the crazy
[__] he was doing he was a [__] great
father and i actually what i got out of
that thing
was um
i loved the relationship that him and
his son had
it was amazing and then the charisma
of his dad that even the commissioner
of the t of of of the thing and
eventually he couldn't resist the guy's
charisma like i just thought uh and then
all the players [__] loved him oh
dude
yeah there was something like
beyond it was like family
yeah and they they also who were they
ripping off they were ripping off the
crooks that run our government so they
was just kind of like all right well
[Laughter]
yeah it was like the bad guys you root
for you know listen i feel like if the
government every once in a while hey
paul you had a good [__] year and
they just dropped 10 grand cash at your
[__] doorstep i think you'd be a
little more patriotic
absolutely no i actually i i um
i was loving watching i love when when
the kid
who's a 17 year old gm when he goes i
just became like this stats geek and
like they started showing all these
codes and stuff and my wife was going oh
was that shade are they making fun of
them and i'm going no no like this watch
this watch this it's a compliment
because he started noticing like
patterns
that's what i liked about it too because
he just reminded me like all the guys i
[__] hung out with
where you're like
you you maybe that you suck at school
but for some reason you're good at like
i don't know watching sports
yeah and i respected that afterwards
he's like i'm not doing anything for my
you know under my dad right now like i'm
trying to do this boxing thing or i have
a gym like he kind of wanted to like do
his own thing i kind of thought like you
watched the guy get like more mature
through
you know it was and i thought he had
that uh
[Music]
it's kind of that dave portnoy like dave
portnoy understands how to run the
circus you know what i mean he
understands his audience and he knows
you know those tough man competitions
and everything everything that [__]
guy does like he exposes me to [__] like
that i didn't even know i was interested
in
it was just like i'm [__] watching
this this is great or the fact that he
goes to like the the smaller markets
and um and shines a light on that i
think all of that stuff's great i think
that kid
with his um
just his skills like his business skills
and all that type of stuff i i think
he's going to do real well in life
yeah he loved it dude i thought i was
going to watch and it was just gonna be
like
hey this guy who's shady did this thing
i loved it
it was like these guys were actually
really good at it
yeah
they all those guys go to the place
right the the ice thing where i take
sophia and i love it at the end when he
was crying one of the guys was crying he
goes he didn't rat he never radished so
my favorite guy was the tele survivalist
looking guy yeah yeah what was it what
was i i forget the guy's name or jimmy
whatever he goes he goes you don't tell
jimmy to shut the [__] up
nobody
shut the [__] up and then he takes like
these two pictures on the cigar
we're talking about this like everybody
watching you should definitely
check it out and another thing too that
they crushed the logo
i was gonna say how glasses were [__]
hold it the garbage can holding the
stick it was the [__] like i i literally
went in just in the way that they put it
together like when they first met his
kid
he was a punk he looked like a punk with
his double earrings and stuff and they
set it up like you weren't gonna love
the kid
by the end and in the end i was just
like i respect him this [__] kid's
like really good
at running a team
yeah yeah it was great
how great was that that his dad just
bought him a team and says dad's just
like yeah it's your team do what you
want it's like epic
how not to say that his dad didn't know
[__] about hockey wasn't really into the
game
and they they just just go [__] it we're
doing this
and they would
they ended up being great at it
yeah
that was probably
that one i watched the and one
one that one was i didn't like that one
because i was rooting for them to be the
man i got to tell you the three that i
watched all were home runs the trashers
one was great the manti tail thing was
great and the tim donaghy thing they
were all [__] really good watches man
they ran out was hard to watch because
dude that was tough dude because he was
so sheltered with good people around him
that he never anticipated that anybody
would do something like that like yeah
he was be like his be that's a great
like perfect way to say his bewilderment
of how evil is out there he's like
trying to help somebody dude it was
[__] up and then he's like i'm on
stage holding the heisman trophy
knowing now that i got [__] duped and
they asked me about it he's like i
didn't know i couldn't lie in that
moment it was just the whole thing was
[__] up man really [__] down you
gotta listen to a bunch of dirt bags
like dude
how could you not know like all that
monday morning quarterback [__] dude i
can tell you something right now
if when i was his age someone could have
got me like that too
100 percent
yeah dude and he was like i was the most
sheltered
gullible sheltered in a different way
like just completely
walked dude he was in like freezing ass
indiana like his whole family was in
hawaii he sees an attractive woman start
talking to him and then says all and
he's like trying to i get it dude i mean
three years is a like his best friend
was like after a while it started to get
but look man
i feel bad i felt bad for the kid you
could have strung me along for a good
nine months
ten months
oh sorry bill i'm busy again this
weekend no that's okay i'm already
typing away well me being as close with
you as i am
after you told me like
this is this is our relationship after
you told me after six months i be like
dude she gonna come to the school and
visit and then if you were like
i gotta be honest with you that's kind
of
you know
and that's the way you would go into it
with these questions
so you still haven't seen her i'm
thinking i'm just asking you know just
what about uh you know 100 maybe you
guys could like facetime have you
you facetimed at all
yeah and then when you were like i'd be
like have you ever seen her and if
you're like no dude i actually never saw
her then i'd be like yeah dude you might
wanna i gotta be honest with you paul i
kind of feel that way when i watch you
with the packers every year
i mean you would literally think that
you live in appleton wisconsin the way
you were you were like ride or die
i wouldn't say there did like the giants
are here and the packers and aaron
rodgers
is right here
i it's it's actually it is it's
alarming and it actually makes me
question my decisions i just he just
lures me along because
how many times are you gonna go [__]
13 wins and lose the first run at home i
i i don't know i just love how you
talked about yourself like you you it
wasn't even you as some governmental
agency
it's alarming and it's actually bringing
up a lot of
concern that was almost sociopathic yeah
i mean this time this [__] guy i was
watching one of those behind the scenes
in jail thing one of those [__]
horrifying things and this guy like
killed his
killed his [__] uh uh cell mate
well i just bludgered him to death and
at some point they were trying to find
the guy's like eye or ear and they
couldn't find it and they go what
happened to it and the guy goes we don't
know
we don't know
like somebody else
like he wasn't the more person
he was using was
it was like he was part of the
investigation
dude you did this [__]
dude
when oprah sat down with lance armstrong
and she goes and then and then you did
this and he goes i know sick it's sick
and he goes and he goes even more sick
everybody like imagine me like in like a
sitting around people and they were just
like a professional goes pawlik you you
you picked aaron rodgers again like i'm
just like i know it's it's i don't know
it's wow it's like i i can't even wrap
my head around it
like paul we're still talking about
something you did right oh it's so great
i mean i i get it dude it's it's it's
aaron rodgers but like i i just i look
at i mean i picked him this week but i
just feel like
the level of frustration he has with
that franchise speaks volumes to me that
like
he you know the quarterback knows
at this point like playing as long as
him how much he understands the game
he's basically a head coach
or a [__] coach on some level playing
the game
and if
he's that frustrated paul
yeah he might want to take the hint paul
when the commander-in-chief of the
football team is going what the [__] are
we doing here
yeah paul you're just taking you're
throwing good money after bad
yeah one of my favorite expressions i
still never quite understood it and then
when i when i watch them i go like this
i'll be like how many times are you
going to lose in the first round at
lambeau after a bye and it's it's crazy
but we'll see what happens we'll see
what happens i'd like your pick i would
have you know i would have taken them i
like that little edge you know we'll see
what happens
we'll see what happens like you don't
like that i'm quite like somewhere to
stop being fun now you're questioning
like why are you questioning yourself at
what point does aaron rodgers become
since he's one of the greatest ever get
a second ring is it gonna happen or is
it not gonna happen you know that's the
other thing it's like is the guy ever
gonna [__] just go on a rock i love
that he got a ring so all those [__]
unathletic [__] sports writers aren't
riding his ass about that because
there's nothing that they love better
than a [__] guy way more talented
with a way better looking girlfriend in
a car not getting a ring that's how they
get all they they get really excited
about that
yeah he hasn't won the big one though
some guy literally sitting there eating
a donut paul happy happy he didn't just
sit here yeah he never did it
[Laughter]
all right well guys i mean what else do
you want what else could we do for you i
mean you got our first week picks where
we can
i can't even tell you i want these i
want our listeners
we got to hit these monday night
specials we owe it to them paul
anything better than listening to the
two [__]
give you some monday night i know you're
going dude i'm not a [__] don't
[__] drag me into that no no no i'm
knocking around guys
two recovered meat heads you want to go
with that
i will
you know this year i want to ryan i want
to beat the book twice in a row and then
have people go were you at espn where
you had [__] dude i want to beat
these guys so bad they try to bring us
in the fold you know like when they
catch a good cheek for the casino and
you end up working at the casino
i want to turn down guys like colin
cowherd when they want to come on go nah
look at this paul we had one winning
year look at this [__] we're talking
just i'm [__] around um but i would i
would like to have another year so
people aren't like oh foof that second
year or those are right it's like
rodney's joke i'm all right this week
last one goes in rough [__] i want to
walk into bed mgm and everyone looks at
the ground
oh yeah no oh all right there we go
cigar all right everybody there you go
you're buying a selling
what's that mac jones you're buying a
selling oh no i'm buying i'm buying
after what i saw last year yeah i think
i think this is this is his breakout
year yeah i mean you can't if you sell
on that you're just not paying attention
to football
all right
you know you're not paying attention to
football but you know the guy i'm real
big on this year
is is uh justin herbert
that's the guy i'm i'm watching
i love him i think he slings it like a i
mean duty six six he's got a great but
you like you said their defense needs to
be uh they gotta have a d6 dude how much
bigger a quarterback's gonna get dude
dude he's six oh by the way i know i
know we gotta get out aaron judge hit
54. he's got a month
he's got a month to get eight
all right
i respect for you paul i'm staying away
from the conversation of the new york
yankees right now
okay wow
you've always been a class act
i'm not bringing them up
okay
all right what do we got andrew we're
good we got we go we got the monday
night special we got our picks in
everybody's good everybody's happy it's
four o'clock on the button and what else
do these people want from us other than
a win on set on monday night no we gotta
hit we gotta hit the monday night
specials paul
we gotta we gotta get him a couple all
right that's it all right we're babbling
here all right that's it paul uh
happy to be able to do this again with
you this year thank you to bet mgm for
letting us do this thanks to all the
fans for listening and let's watch some
football baby
all right man i'll talk to you soon all
right we'll see you all right everybody
that is it thank you guys so much and
again please do not forget to uh to bet
with us and to bet on the best app there
is out there and the best lines go to
the bet mgm app download it use bonus
code bur that's b-u-r-r
uh and you will get a hundred percent
risk-free uh bet up to a thousand
dollars with your first wager again
here's how it works you download the bet
mgm app you sign up using bonus code
burr deposit at least ten dollars and
place your first wager on any game
you'll receive up to a thousand dollars
in free bets if your bet loses
just make sure you use bonus code burr
that's b-u-r-r when you sign up enjoy it
bet with us bet responsibly and have a
good time and remember guys tibet you
got to be 21 years of age or older to
wager in arizona colorado dc iowa
indiana kansas michigan mississippi new
jersey new york nevada pennsylvania
tennessee
virginia west virginia or wyoming only
new customer offer paid in free bets
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions
uh excludes michigan disassociated
persons
uh please gamble responsibly gambling
problem call 1-800 next step for arizona
call 1-800-522-47004
colorado dc nevada wyoming west virginia
1-800-270-7117
for confidential help michigan
1-800 gambler in indiana new jersey
pennsylvania and west virginia
1-800 bets off in iowa call or text the
tennessee red line
800-889-9789 in tennessee or call
1-888-777-9696 from mississippi
sports betting is void in georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
nevada
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is the monday morning podcast for
monday september 8th
2014 how are you how's it going
two weeks in a row [__] you i'm excited
i told you last week how excited i was
about the nfl football season starting
you know and um
kind of sucked for me because i missed
all of it basically i was flying back
from toronto
um i went up there for the toronto
international film festival the
international film festival held up
there in toronto
um because i got a movie uh i don't have
a movie i have a partner movie
take the ego down a little bit do you
really have a movie what do you have
bill do you have a home movie that you
shot about you rubbing your balls in
your bed
all right relax i have a part in a movie
called black and white starring kevin
costner
and octavia spencer
directed by mike binder
um
i really want to see somebody from
boston talking about this movie
when it's coming out somebody at a lower
level who hasn't taken a speech class
career speech is what they call it you
know when you get into mainstream media
good evening welcome to the nightly news
and you can't tell where the person's
from no accent
so basically everybody can understand
you slash they're not laughing at the
way you speak
you know i i want to see the local
person in boston doing this
new movie coming out black and white
starring kevin costner octavius spencer
directed by mike binder
[Applause]
come on down to mvp sports we got all
the jerseys we got the sharks the
steelers the charges and more
um
anyways that's actual copy for a long
time ago from an mtv uh mtv mvp sports
radio spot we got the sharks the
steelers the chargers and more more
do you really have more you don't have
less no we got more
um jaymore
anyways um yeah so i was on the plane
i missed
i missed all the games
i missed all the games uh miss my
patriots
getting their asses
in the second half evidently
by the miami dolphins and um i want to
uh i wish i maybe the nfl network will
re-show
some of it i want to watch it i want to
see what happened
um i was actually on the plane coming
back flying air canada
and um i'm thinking
all right well well let me take you
through the whole thing i flew up uh
was it friday night
me and the lovely neo we flew up there
for the film festival and um i shot this
movie last year remember last year when
i told you i was in new orleans for
those of you who were listening last
year
you know we shot this movie and i lucked
out because it was hard as balls
the level of humidity was something i
had never experienced other than when i
was in new york city and i remember late
night standing on a subway platform
underground
and basically i mean it was already hot
as [__]
outside and then underground you
basically with this air that was trapped
after the sun had been beating on the
asphalt above
heating up all the air underneath for 24
[__] hours whatever the hell it was
and was just standing there like a
[__] zombie in late night if you
never lived you know in a city the
trains don't run like every six seven
minutes if you miss a train you're gonna
be there for an ungodly like 20 25
minutes
and usually what you're thinking is is
please don't let anybody crawl up
from the tracks
and you know drag you know four or five
of them
grab me by the legs and pull me under to
their underworld cities and use me as a
food source that's what you're usually
worried about or getting stabbed or
getting robbed or whatever
on that particular night none of that
entered into my mind i was just standing
there
um
i remember early on before i got
delusional i was wondering hey what if i
i should probably not stand too close to
the track because if i get so dehydrated
and passed out and fall onto the tracks
i'm gonna get run over
um
it was just brutal so what anyways i had
not experienced heat like that
that anyways down in new orleans
since my days living in new york city
and um
i really lucked out
if you go and see the film which i hope
you do
it did really well
at the festival and um
i remembered i just totally lucked out
where all of my scenes were indoors
i only had one scene where i had to get
out of a car
and just walk up
to uh kevin's character's house
but other than that i was inside
the whole [__] time
even when i was outside i was inside i
was to be sitting in a car and we'd be
cranking the ac and then shut it off
right before they did the take i
completely [__] lucked out
but anyways so um
went up there for the premiere
and uh
it was a uh
it was an awesome time got to see
everybody in the cast it's an unreal
cast anthony mackie's in it
um i play a lawyer
i play a lawyer and uh
i'm representing kevin costner and
anthony mackie represents octavia
spencer's family
and
you know it was pretty insane it was
definitely
one of those
how the hell did i end up here moments
what am i doing here
and how soon am i gonna get fired you
know one of those deals
and uh fortunately none of that happened
and i had a great time but uh so anyways
it's been a year since i've seen
everybody in the cast or whatever so we
all got to hang out
um
got to watch the film
in front of a crowd which is [__]
nerve-racking but fortunately they got
on early they got on the ride early and
they just you know
and uh went great
it went great
and i had a great time we went to the
after parties did all of that type of
stuff
blah blah blah blah blah blah blue and
all that you know it's funny when we
went to the premiere was hilarious was
there they bring you over there right
and like it's this huge film festival i
come from the stand-up world so i have
no idea so
um there's all these big time movie
actors there so anyways when they bring
you over to do the red carpet
um
they drive you over and like you know
wherever the [__] we were at we well we
went to a dinner
no there was an early that's right there
was an early thing you all meet up then
they do the press junkets tell us about
work day on this movie was it exciting
to work with somebody like this guy they
do all that [__] and you just put on
your happy face oh my god it was amazing
everybody was so amazing you just do
that [__] you go into that mode right
so then they bring us over right
and you're pulling up to the red carpet
and there's a [__]
probably
eight nine people deep
wrapped around this semicircle where all
the cars are pulling up because they
want to see all these big-time [__]
hollywood stars
so lo and behold one of the first ones
to come down the [__] path was me
right
i wish i don't i i've never done one of
those i wish i [__] videoed
the looks on people's faces
the [__] manic look of excitement
passed
combined with where is the famous guy
so they're looking they're looking into
the truck
and they're like
and they're looking at me and they
quickly look cuz i just you know i'm
standing there i'm in a suit i look like
a [__] agent they don't know the [__]
i am so
i the door opens and the crowd's like
as i go to get out and immediately
it just [__]
you know like the beginning of a
football game where everybody's going
crazy and you're getting ready for the
for them to kick off and the kicker
starts running at the ball and then the
wind blows it off the tee and then the
crowd has to die down before they start
going
again that's basically what it was me
stepping out of that truck was like the
football
falling off the tee
and uh
you know i was they were they were
looking at nia like she was in the movie
they thought she was in the movie they
were like who is that was is that you
know [__]
is that will smith's wife
um anyways
so then whatever went out and did the
red carpet red carpet was the same
experience which was [__] hilarious
was people talking to me asking me
questions as they were looking down the
carpet to see
you know where the real person was that
was coming so i just started making a
joke everyone i wanted as whenever they
would look i would be like yeah don't
worry kevin's coming kevin's coming you
wrap it up with me wrap it up and they'd
be like oh no no no it's like yes yes
yes i get it him
you're waiting for him
you're not going to use this
so um i had a great time i was making
knee left the whole [__] way down
because i just kept addressing that
and um it was just it was a great time
and uh
you know
i know the whole thing was it was
interesting going through there and they
just some of the questions that they
would ask were kind of like open-ended
they'd be like you know
you know this movie deals with race and
in the light of the colin ferguson
it's like this thing was made a year ago
this was made before then what do you
feel
uh how do you feel that this movie's
going to affect
what am i a [__] sorcerer i don't
know i think people are going to think
what they think
all right bill thank you very much kevin
so anyways uh i got to do all of that
[__]
and um
it was definitely a good time and uh we
saw the movie movie did great and uh the
crowd really seemed to like it blah blah
blah blah
uh we went to the after party
um
and that was a really interesting thing
too because i didn't understand what was
going on we went to this party and we're
sitting at a table and there was
who i thought were these random people
at the table i'm like who are these
[__] people sitting here
why am i talk what am i talking it
turned out these were the people that
put you know a lot of the money up for
the movie so basically for you when you
guys do your movie all right
and you go to your premiere and you step
out and you get to experience what it
feels like to be the human version of a
football falling off a t
um
afterwards you go i guess the next party
you go to
is people that put up you know
i know kevin put up a bunch of money for
the movie and then there was like i
don't know these other people that put
up money for the movie so you they then
have a dinner
and then you go and you interact with
them and basically thank them for
putting the money up for the movie old
[__] freckles didn't realize that
i'm looking at this guy is okay for dude
who the [__] is this guy
um and then once i realized it's like oh
oh oh okay okay oh we're still playing
the game
i thought the game was over you know it
was halftime i thought once we once we
did the whole [__]
premiere of it and it went well i
thought that that was the end of the
[__] and that old billy could start
drinking
so um
i gotta be honest with you i didn't
really drink that that night that was
one of those nights you don't drink
you know you just have to be kind of on
point the entire time but it was uh
it was definitely a lot of fun
unfortunately you know toronto is one of
my favorite [__] cities
i just like going up to canada man i
really enjoy it and uh
but
you know i was only up there for like 24
hours so i didn't get to do some of the
things i got to do when i did the tour
with fersi
um
but definitely stayed at the same hotel
my favorite hotel up there
had a [__] steam room some old man
[__] i got to be honest dude steams are
the best [__] thing ever
you know any one time you smoke a
[__] cigar i swear to god you taste
it the next day until about two in the
afternoon unless you wake up in the
morning
and you go take a steam
you take a steam you just sweat out all
the impurities and i'm telling you that
[__] comes right out you're fine
you're fine you're sweating out all the
cancer
um
anyway so that's the deal so that movie
comes out i believe end of october early
november
i'm definitely going to get uh
mike binder the director who put me in
the [__] movie literally
um
i'm definitely gonna get him on uh the
podcast at some point and possibly uh
maybe another cast member will see we
will definitely see so please look out
for that please go pay to see the movie
please don't steal it
but you know at the end of the day you
have all the power
um
all right let's continue on so anyway so
then then uh i
what did i do yeah okay so the next day
i wake up i take a steam right and i go
over to the [__] airport look at my
old billy fancy pants right taking
steams going to premieres i had a big
weekend i'm not gonna apologize for it
took me 22 years
um
so uh
i went over to the airport and and i'm
sitting
in the uh i'm sitting at the airport and
they have all this nfl pregame going on
and i'm thinking oh [__] i'm gonna miss
everything
and i'm watching the pregame and
which i never watch
and i haven't really watched it in years
it's why i don't know anybody's names
anymore and i'm really bad at i mean
part of it's because i'm on the road all
the [__] time but uh
i think um
i don't know sorry guys can you tell i'm
looking at something else here on the
computer uh so i'm sitting there
watching it and uh the first thing i see
and i started tweeting this [__] and it
kind of started i got a little thing
going on twitter of just the dumb [__]
that they say
in the whole [__] um
the nfl pregame
you know like freeze the tape right
there okay you see right there where
he's making decision he is making
decisions and that is a good thing he's
looking at his not only last year he was
just looking it was his first read he
was telegraphing where he was going to
throw the ball and if you see right here
what he's doing he is now checking down
the field at second and third reads now
i can tell you when a quarterback does
that that is when he's starting to play
the quarterback position at an nfl level
right
[__] all of that [__] just a bunch of
[__] people in suits
breaking down the game the way it never
needed to be broken down
it is completely a product
of [__]
24 9024 sports channels i mean dude i'm
sitting there it's like two and a half
hours
before kickoff and they're already doing
pregame it's like dude pregame used to
be a half hour before
brent musberger irv cross
that kennedy woman whatever the hell
jackie can't not jackie kennedy what the
hell was her name
um
and then jimmy the greek
that was cbs and then nbc you had
[__]
brian gumbel and mike adamly
nfl 81 right that's what the [__] do you
do that's all you just watched that and
they went around the league
and it was cool bing bang boom and you
were done then you went to your local
feed now you just got these guys they're
out there they're acting it out
on that half a football field
over and i'll tell you right now what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to turn around the culture in the locker
room in the locker room for years it is
it has been a mentality that we are not
going to win the big one and that's why
they brought in joe [__] bag of
donuts to come in there and turn around
stupidest [__] ever
over and [__] over and over so anyway
so i go i get on the i started tweeting
all of that [__]
and uh you know just making up player
names
and all the dumb [__] that they said
he's a changed man he came in this came
into camp in the best shape of his
football life
he's listening to his coaches he hasn't
hit his wife and he only tested positive
to weed and i'll tell you that type of
attitude that type of attitude is
contagious in the locker room
how many [__] times did they even sit
there rolling their eyes
with their football speak
drives me up the [__] wall
how anyway she what he needs to do is he
needs to feel the the pass rush you have
to in the national football league what
you have to be able to do is feel when
that pocket is collapsing around you you
gotta have a clock in your head you
gotta have a clock in your head and you
want once it's clicking down you have to
know you must get rid of the football
because i'll tell you right now if you
don't do that you take a sack right
there that that is a drive killer mike
oh absolutely absolutely absolutely
agree what he's doing there is exactly
he's patting the ball he is telegraphing
his passes this is the type of stuff
that they worked on in the off-season he
showed some promising moments in the
preseason but i got to tell you today i
don't know where that was and i gotta
want you i gotta wonder is it time to
hit the panic button down the camera
who the [__] can sit there and watch
that horseshoe then what i love is
sports fans
watch that [__]
and then it gets it's like a virus and
then it gets in their [__] heads
and then they go out to sports bars and
you talk about football and then they
start sounding like those people
yo try you know
dude you gotta have a [__] clock in
your head kid
you know
one one thousand
two one thousand [__] get rid of it
throw it out of bounds
dude you're allowed to do that as long
as you're within the confines of the
[__] pocket dude
i i can't
i can't [__]
i can't go to sports bars
why would you i don't give a [__] how
[__] broke you are there is no reason
to not have the nfl package there isn't
all right
you can go 40 [__] days without food
as long as you got water you're fine do
yourself a [__] favor starve yourself
and yes
okay i'm advocating anorexia to get the
nfl package to not go down
to the [__] sports bar eating that
heart attack food
watching a bunch of grown men walking
around in jerseys like they're dating
dating the [__] player
do it all day all day
that horse [__]
you're gonna go down there looking at
those tired waitresses trying to [__]
it up in their [__] cut off ref shirt
listening to that [__]
unbeliever is it time to make a change
i'll tell you i mean if i'm if i am if i
am the offensive coordinator he has had
you gotta understand with this kid this
kid has had 19 offensive coordinators in
the last seven seasons okay i i still
don't think that we have seen what this
kid
is able to do out there i'm still
holding on yes but you have to
understand that he has had a change
i i don't know i can't [__] right right
i'm annoying myself just just even
listening to this [__] so anyway so i
get on the [__] plane
and all i want to do is watch the game
and uh
you know it's funny to watch a [__]
game
on a plane i've been able to it's just
it's the best it just [__]
blows through
the whole flight i mean three hours i
mean you just crushed your flight
and uh so i get on there you know
somebody always has money on it or
somebody is like totally into the team
you know you know what's funny is that
the game's kind of boring and then you
turn it right and then all of a sudden
something exciting happens and you hear
these guys like
whatever like 10 rows back going like
yeah
and you [__] quickly turn it back on
um you start watching it it's the best
time of the year to fly
provided you're on like a virgin or a
jet blue or something like that that's
gonna american airlines where they're
gonna have the [__] game
uh unfortunately i was on air canada
we don't give a [__] about you
and you're american sports you know what
they had
i saw sports and my heart is like
pumping going oh my god
i'm gonna have nfl football all right
i'm going to be flying over
what's the closest nfl city to toronto
is it cleveland or is it detroit both
are separated by water right what game
am i going to get am i going to get
pittsburgh [__] cleveland
uh did detroit play i don't even [__]
know i missed everything um am i gonna
get the chicago game hey maybe i'll get
lucky and i'll get to watch my patriots
play the miami dolphins right
so i click on the sports little thing
there
and unfortunately i got uh
all they had was taped games games that
already happened and it was highlights
from the 2014 world cup
so
i did what any man does in those moments
i can't watch sports i'm going to watch
a documentary because that's the only
other thing that's going to [__] be
engaging
enough
um
oh [__] 22 minutes i got to read some
advertising here hang on a second hang
on hang on hang on hang on
um all right
oh speaking of football everybody
fantasy football players i got something
here for you all right if you just want
to stop talking trash to your friends
you know actually want to make a little
bit of dough
we got the draftkings
the draftkings everybody
sounds like a doo-wop group um fantasy
football's back and
draftkings.com is not messing around
draftkings.com is america's favorite
one-week fantasy football site where you
could win enormous cash prizes every
single week you've already researched
the players for your season-long fantasy
team turn that knowledge into instant
cash at where
draftkings.com last year one player
turned 11 bucks into four grand in one
weekend
i'm i'm calling this right now this
website is gonna be huge
um another one a hundred grand his first
time ever playing and another player won
a million bucks in one day just playing
fantasy football
keep your season long league where it is
but also play one week fantasy at
draftkings.com to win huge caches to win
huge cash this weekend hurry get free
entry into a millionaire
maker event where first place takes home
a million bucks head over to
draftkings.com now and enter promo code
defense
d-e-f-e-n-s-e to play uh free to become
a millionaire draftkings.com bigger
events bigger winner winnings bigger
millionaires damn it i almost got
through it enter defense for free entry
now at draftkings.com draftkings.com
that's draftkings.com
um dude that website is going to be huge
all right dollar shave club everybody
ever wonder why razors are so expensive
i mean does it make any sense big shape
companies are changing are charging you
for ridiculous shaving technology you
don't need first vibrating handles then
flashlights now pivot ball flex heads
what's going to happen next mp3 players
what else do we need in there you know
enough is enough join
dollarshaveclub.com for a few bucks a
month dollarshave.com delivers the
world's best razors right to your front
door
not only are they cheaper they bring
them right to you this is the greatest
idea ever
i think dollarshaveclub.coms are better
than the big shape companies for a
fraction of the price is so easy go to
dollarshaveclub.com pick up one of their
raises they start at three bucks a month
you don't have to break the bank you
don't have to get in your car you don't
have to resort to cheap disposable
raises to save cash
dollarshave.com.com is amazing every
month they ship you automatic deliveries
you'll never forget to buy blades again
you don't have to squeeze
squeeze shaves out of a dull dirty old
razor blade alright this is a joke this
is a no-brainer you get to shave with
the fresh blade every week this is
absolutely mandatory for anyone that
wants a great shape you deserve better
than a dullo blade you know
and you have a finite time on the planet
earth why waste it standing in line at
cvs no more ridiculous shaving
technology make the smarter choice go to
dollarshaveclub.com slash burr b-u-r-r
that's dollarshaveclub.com
all right
back to the podcast so anyway so i get
on the [__] plane and i click on and
all they have is highlights of the world
cup and i'm thinking all right i deserve
that karmically i've done enough piece
of [__] things in life i deserve the
fact that nfl football is not on right
now and i have to watch
world cup repeats of world cup soccer
which i would watch if there was an nfl
football on
the real football
not the football the rest of the world
plays
you know what the rest of the world is
they like a bunch of mainstream [__]
hacks
you know they all want the same football
right like that [__] teeny bopping
[__]
whatever the [__] her name is miley
cyrus like if she [__] played a sport
she'd play soccer american football
that's like the underground band with
balls
that's trying to stick it to the man man
sorry whatever i like nfl football go
[__] yourselves all right
with your [__] bangers and mash
anyways um
the [__] am i talking about so i get on
this oh yeah so i i'm like what am i
going to watch here so i started
watching this documentary
about this dolphin that was hanging out
around
new zealand
and this woman started hanging out with
the dolphin started thinking about the
dolphin in the middle of the night if it
was lonely and she'd go in the water
with the thing it got really [__]
creepy
you know when people start [__]
befriending a wild animal especially
when it lives in a [__] uh world that
you can't breathe in
you know
i guess it's a mammal so it comes to the
surface is that the connection
i was like wow you have to come up for
air too
so she started getting really creepy
close with this dolphin and then they
started showing the fishermen that were
getting annoyed by the dolphin because
it was eating all the fish and it was
getting right to that point where i'm
like something tragic is going to happen
to this doll and i'm going to start
welling up tearing up on an airplane and
i don't want this to happen so i turn
the channel that's how i watch all
nature shows i watch the part about the
animal and right when it gets to the
point and then man came and they show
that [__] machine that just pulls
trees out of the ground like the hulk
have you ever seen that [__] thing
where one man in this goddamn machine
could do more [__] damage
than a [__] hurricane you know
so i kind of knew i was going to tap out
so i tapped out on that and i
decided to watch some classic tv
and um
this made me feel really old
in classic tv they actually had wkrp in
cincinnati
and i remember when that show came out i
used to watch it every week
you guys remember that show
no well here's a little reminder
baby if you ever wondered
maybe there's a fresh remember
you remember you wander whatever became
of me
i'm living on the air in cincinnati
cincinnati w-k-r-p
remember that
bill there's no way you're going to sing
the whole song got
tired and unpacking
time to town up and down the dial
maybe you and me were never meant to be
just baby think of me once in a while
i'm at w
so i watched an episode of that and i
got to tell you
i don't think i've ever seen a writer's
room just tap out the way they did at
the end of that episode
it was this [__] episode where dr
johnny fever
they have basically they're giving away
five thousand dollars
like a hundred bucks at a time
throughout the summer
and johnny fever reads it wrong and says
it's a five thousand dollar giveaway
so they go [__] what are we gonna do i
mean mr carlson who runs the the station
goes
if we have to give away five grand not
only is fever losing his job for some
reason
uh andy travis
is also going to lose his job as well as
venus flytrap who's another [__] dj
but i guess they threw him in because he
was african-american well [__] you we've
been looking for a reason to get rid of
you anyways because this is cincinnati
in 1979.
so what do they do they go all right you
basically you gotta name
five songs only hearing a couple of
notes so they splice them together so
[__] quickly they don't think
anybody's gonna get
get it but of course somebody gets it
and now they got five grand of cash
everybody's gonna lose their [__]
money
and then what ends up happening is this
guy shows up to claim the money they
give the guy the money and he leaves and
then two seconds later the real guy
shows up and they realize they gave away
the wrong money but johnny fever smelled
a rat and he went down and he got the
money back and hands it to mr carlson
and that evidently made it all better
and then they ended the episode it's
like oh wait a minute what about the guy
who actually won it he's standing there
you still got to give him the five grand
and then it just ended
may play the ends the end song
[__] i'm not even exaggerating that's
how the song goes at the end of wkrp you
can't understand one [__] word
he had a rainbow and a free girlfriend
and then the cat comes up wow
and that was 70s [__] television
sorry anyways um
so let's get to my [__] my new
england patriots i didn't see anything
of the game i just saw the highlights
but uh
i got to admit i can't say dude i called
it
i can't remember if i said it on this
podcast i said it to a friend of mine
where i thought this year the patriots
were going to dip a little bit in
everybody else in our
division
was gonna get a little bit better it's
just uh
it's just what it is it is what it is
you can only be on top for so [__]
long we've been on top of our division
anyways for a long [__] time and um
i don't know
i don't know it just seemed like we were
actually doing okay against the team
was it like 20 to 10 or something like
that at the half
and then we just
we couldn't do anything
after i'll tell you they went in and
they made the halftime adjustments and
then the patriots never adjusted to
those halftime judgment i gotta tell you
you know
i for one i didn't like that trade when
they let logan mankins go i mean
[__] the tackle i mean he protects
the boys
i'm sure they're doing all of that [__]
and everybody freaking the [__] out
about where the patriots are okay first
of all it's only one week and then
second of all
you know not for nothing
we're on a 14 season run
i think we've won the division every
[__] year it saved me except maybe
once or twice
throughout tom's whole career i think
the jets won it one year
um
no they couldn't want to didn't win that
year because we never played them
in a way game they always came up to to
me i don't [__] know
um all i remember the year uh brady went
down and we went eleven and five and we
didn't make the [__] playoffs i think
when we had matt castle
and that was when paul versi said matt
castle's for real
the guy's for real
he's mobile in the pocket blah blah all
that type of [__] i was like dude
he he's [__] he went 11-5 with the
16-0 team last year in the regular
season he lost five more games than the
team did it's the fact that you're
counting down from 16 and now it's 11.
if they won 12 the year before
all right do the [__] math i had to
say that to give myself a [__] chance
to catch up they would oh they would
have gone seven and nine
right what i say five less five less
from twelve yeah seven and nine
then you would have been like this guy
stink ship them out of [__] town
um so anyways uh i would say that logan
mankins
was uh
i mean obviously that was a main
a main point
but it also sounded like they they are
once again our [__] defense
is another issue and uh
i don't know man i i didn't see the game
but it sounded like you know we got
vince wilfork back and it just sounded
like they just kind of went through our
defense like butter
uh
so we will see what happened i'm by no
means conceding the whole [__] year
because of one week
but um
you gotta be honest like as a sports fan
how long can the patriots keep winning
the vision that the afc east and how
long can the bills jets and dolphins
suck
i mean you suck every year you got to be
drafting really high
right
at some point you got to pick somebody i
don't even know the name of the dolphins
quarterback but i kind of looked up his
stats from last year the guy almost
threw for 4 000 yards
the guy he's no slouch
and i'll tell you you know these teams
they know each other they meet twice a
year these teams they know what they do
and i'll tell you right now it's hard to
beat three times one season
um
so it's going to be really interesting
to see uh
i don't know i'm a [__] nerd man i i
still love this [__] even even if we
suck this year i'm still going to watch
every game unless you know i'm on a
goddamn airplane
but uh
[Music]
you know it is what it is you can only
[__]
hang in there for so goddamn long not to
mention bill belichick has been the guy
so everybody dissects what the [__] it
is you do they take your coaching staff
and everything the fact that he's been
able to go on the run that he's been
able to go on this is [__] amazing
and also how excited people were when
they saw tom with his head down
you know in the towel over his head like
he had [__] uh congestion or
something like that right
congested nose failure whatever the [__]
it is um
that actually made me laugh like people
like best picture of tom brady ever all
that says to me as a patriots fan is
this guy's been raping you for [__]
the better part of a decade and a half
all right
um so we shall see we'll we will see
what's going on i missed everything i
missed college football i missed
absolutely [__] everything i don't
even know what happened so i'm just
gonna shut up about it
um and with that let me get into uh some
of the reads this week
uh the mother moaning park didn't do
anything else
i'm trying to think oh you know what i
was watching last night you know i'm
[__] car crazy right now
and i watched this great uh
this great youtube video
of um
the [__] mercedes-benz sls
amg gt
right that one that opens up like the
original one from 1955 with the gull
wings
and uh it has a base price of 221
and you know those are the kind of cars
that you look at
i was looking at the roadster by the way
which i guess is 228 thousand
eighty dollars these are the kind of
cars that you look at when you go on the
[__] internet it's great because back
in the day you would you would actually
have to go down to the lot if they even
had one and they would chase you away
they'd see you walking up going oh no
[__] get out of here you [__] bum
we got chevettes down the street there
freckles
so what i love about this thing is you
can actually what like i watched a whole
test drive this guy drove it through um
you know he started off on the coast of
portland and road drove it all the way
up to mount hood and what was funny is a
lot of the roads he was on or at least
the areas he was on i've actually been
i've actually driven on but probably in
like a [__]
a chevy lumina or a dodge neon or of
what else that i always [__] end up
getting somehow
ford taurus if i uh
splurge for the full-size car i used to
do this gig this college down in coos
bay
on the coast of portland and uh i used
to drive down because i was trying to
save money
and uh i used to always do it i would i
would you know i'd have a gig on the
[__] western part of nebraska and i
would fly into lincoln and then just get
on the 80
i still remember the highways the 80.
the 80 was all the way across nebraska
the 70
that was uh
kansas
then when you got up north it was 90 and
94 and that went through like
the dakotas and wyoming and montana
and then nuts
and i think it's the 40
is south of the 70.
for those who haven't done a lot of road
[__] uh
even numbers go east-west on the
interstates and odds go north-south
that's some truck and [__] for you
all right and it starts out on the west
coast
pacific coast highway let me see how
much this is my ocd kicking in you got
what is that that's root one but they
got a root one on [__] east coast too
whatever you got the five
right that goes from san diego all the
way up to the [__] canadian border
then you got the 15 and i believe the 15
that goes off of the 10 goes all the way
up to vegas continues up
through utah then you can make a right
at the 70 and take that all the way to
new york i've done that but if you
continue on up which i've never done
that goes right up that splits [__]
nevada in half
and i think it goes up to boise idaho or
into montana or some [__]
then you got the 25
which is basically it starts in breaking
bad country
goes right up through denver
cheyenne wyoming all the way up to [__]
in the middle of why uh [__] montana
then you got the 35
i took that one drove that one up from
austin texas up to dallas that one goes
right up to [__] oklahoma right
through [__] all the way up
then i don't know where it goes from
there
i never did the it was 65 or something
you can take that from indianapolis down
to nashville
or something like that some 60 something
i used to do that all the time when i
was trying to sell tickets down south i
do bob and tom
and uh
i don't know and then all the [__]
rest of them 95 and all those [__]
sorry
anyways so i'm watching this [__]
video and i just do this gig down there
in coos bay
and uh so this guy's driving this for
you got to see this [__] car dude
it's a [__] goddamn james bond car
um
it's unbelievable
i was actually looking at it going you
know what if i sold my house
and i just put it all into that car
[Music]
you got to hear the thing it's just
[__] insane
i am completely sold on german cars i
just think they're the [__] best um i
do like italian cars too but you know
the germans they just take it to that
next level and it really is because they
don't they just don't care about human
life
you know what i mean
they don't and i i know that you're
saying well what about all the safety
they're doing that
for their aryan brothers
they're doing that to protect the next
fear that's why they
they make the car as safe
as it is but it's not for guys like me
like you know if hitler
if hitler like succeeded
okay
and he exterminated all the people he
wanted to exterminate how long
would a [__]
redhead like me be able to be able to
stand in his vicinities before i'm sick
of looking at that to get rid of it
i never would have [__] made it
um
anyways
he'd throw me in right after the [__]
albinos
um so anyways yeah their cars are just
[__] insane and uh i am still 100
hooked on that uh
i think the [__] mercedes-benz
station wagon amg is one of the coolest
[__] cars out there just as far as a
sleeper i just think that is the sickest
car i got a couple of videos i i'll i'll
send you a link of the video for um
for that that that uh
that mercedes sls gt roadster that this
guy took it was just it just was the
[__] [__]
you know what i mean
oh my god why did i look at that [__]
car that's just that's why i you know
you know you ever go like when they have
open houses
and you know in a nice neighborhood and
you're [__]
you're with you know whoever the [__]
hey let's go look let's just [__]
that's the worst thing you could ever
[__] do
you know
because then you got to go back to where
you live
[Laughter]
and that's i'm warning you right now
that you're going to watch this video
and just know that you're then going to
have to go back to the car that you're
driving
and um
whatever i love my prius go [__]
yourself but jesus christ
is that a [__] unbelievable car god
damn it you [__]
you should have to be making a certain
amount of [__] money before you they
even let you watch that video
you know
[__] all right anyways let's uh let's
let's continue on here with with the
podcast um
all right this was an interesting email
because this could go like 9000
different ways all right it says black
guy voice
it says bill my girlfriend and i have
found a hot button issue between uh the
two of us
she hates a black guy voice that i do
when i make jokes he goes i'm not black
and neither is she uh when we started
dating i didn't really do it but when we
were playing monopoly with one of my
oldest friends and i started winning
once and once i was winning and my
oldest friend was there
the old black guy voice made an
appearance i don't really say racist
things what does that mean i don't
really say racist thing or are you
saying like i don't really say racist
thing i can't tell because you're
writing this stuff so he goes i would
just say stuff like oh yeah give me that
dollar or this is some serious cheddar
right here i'm not gonna try to even do
a [__] black guy voice here a hacky
one uh
he goes i also show showered my dog in
500 bills and rubbed it all over his
body like i was uh at a
like it was a party
my friend found it hilarious my
girlfriend said i was mocking her
i love that she's making it about her i
thought that she was going like listen
what you're doing is funny if you're
doing it like if your heart's in the
right place but she's she this is all
about her she goes he goes personally i
think she's i think
being an [__] is an expected part of
the game i guess the game of monopoly
but that's just me he goes now that
we've moved in together i continue to do
the voice in a playful way
uh if she asks for a favor i might reply
sure dog i got you see i think that's
[__] funny
um he goes and then she glares at me and
tells me she hates that voice she
doesn't understand
this is when it gets weird though he
goes then i'm making fun of people who
talk like that and i'm not trying to
make fun of her this is where it goes
off to raise rails for me
uh
and i don't know but i don't know how
you're making fun of him are you just
being ridiculous like the way i'll do
like a southern voice
like man goddammit get your [__] ass
in here ask for a sandwich
right
and is that what is the rule because i'm
making fun of redneck white people and
i'm white i'm allowed to do that
um
it all depends on it real all of this
[__] it all depends on how you're doing
it like what your point is
um
anyway so he goes i don't i don't really
know what
he goes i don't really know what she
thinks i'm
i'm doing honestly i don't see what
is so offensive about the voice
and then he writes no i mean
i like saying ah [__] and [__]
i like referring to our middle-aged
white neighbor as that ghetto ass n-word
i think it's funny now i got to be
honest with you even that is funny if
you're just [__] a white guy
calling some middle-aged white dude
especially
if he looks like flanders
i don't know and i know you're not
supposed to say that but you're in your
house you're [__] around it's your
world it's your tv station and i really
think if you if you if you're not
doing any of this maliciously like that
that's funny
i think it's funny anyways but i don't
know where you're coming from with this
sir anyways he goes my question is
do you think i should stop doing the
voice or do i have the right to continue
doing it you obviously have a right to
continue doing it um he goes i don't
consider it racist and it's really just
for laughs as a comedian i think you can
appreciate that is my girlfriend being
too touchy about it and even if she is
being too touchy do i really have a say
in it
is this the end of the black guy voice
as we know it
i don't even know what that means
sometimes i insist on her adding the
word dj before my name when she speaks
to me
see dude i think you're just being silly
but i just do that because i know it
pisses her off and it's funny
i'm not really an [__] bill i uh if
you think i should stop i actually will
it's time for a third third-party way on
this well the fact that you say if i
actually said stop you will i think
you're i it all depends on how you mean
this but i
this actually
relates
to stand-up comedy right now where uh
you know there's a lot of this people go
out and they see your act
they see a bunch of comedians or they
listen to you tell a bunch of jokes and
then they pick out one joke
and they define you they define you by
that joke
by how they heard the joke and they
define your entire career by that
performance
you know what i mean i mean i i had some
blogger go off on me
um about a show i did recently and it's
like i just taped
i just taped an hour and a half special
i just burned an hour and a half of
material
i wasn't ready to go back out on the
road
i had that [__] goddamn
mississippi river go through the lower
part of my [__] house
and
i have to make money
or else i'm gonna go under right
basically you know i'm gonna get myself
in a ridiculous amount of [__] debt
so i went out before i was ready to go
out and i am i need material and i you
know one of these shows that somebody
complained about was it was a city that
i went to a year ago and i'm not going
out there repeating material
i'm not [__] people over so i went
out there
and i did my thing
and you know my act where my act is
right now i don't like where my act is
right now
at all
no comic does two months after they take
a special nobody is happy with their
[__] actors if you really you know
being honest with yourself
so this person saw me
and you know didn't like what i was
talking about and absolutely you know
i mean i just skimmed them somebody sent
me a link i just skimmed it i didn't
really [__] read it but it was just
like
you know i wouldn't argue with a lot of
your perception of it but to define me
as a stand-up comic on one [__] show
you know when i'm trying to try it's
like doing stand-up comedy it's not like
playing guitar i can't sit in my bedroom
and get better at it and when it's ready
to be heard go out and go play i have to
[__] go out there and just
it's like [__] cooking pasta remember
the old days you took a noodle out you
threw it at the wall and if it stuck it
was done if it wasn't you kept going
that's what you're doing
so this person [__] didn't like what
i was talking about absolutely trashed
me and then
like lied
like completely either lied or was so
wrapped up in how much they didn't like
what i was talking about that they
didn't see what happened i mean the show
i did i got a partial standing ovation
and they called me back out and this
person left all of that out
left all of that [__] out
it was just like he was a monster he was
saying
you know
it's just one of those things where if
you're joking
if you're [__] joking then like i
don't think the other person
you know they can take it however they
want to take it but just because they
decide to take it seriously doesn't mean
that you now meant it
and um
that's sort of like a uh that's kind of
something that's going on so what i
would say as far as what you're doing
is you know if you're not a racist guy
if you don't have issues and you're just
doing it because it's a funny character
and i get doing a character
that drives
your wife up the wall i actually the
character you do i will say
i mean i don't drop the n word but i
will say
that i will do that type of slang
but what i do it is i
i do it in my voice and i say it really
seriously
because it it sounds absolutely grating
to my wife
and it either really makes her laugh or
annoys the [__] out of her so
um
i don't know i think that's part of
being with somebody is you have to have
something that you do that they find
annoying and you find hilarious so
um
you know i don't know
it all it all depends
i think it's funny that
actually i can't even get give her [__]
that she she's making it about herself
that actually
is kind of one for your side that the
way you're doing it isn't in a racist
way but she just doesn't like it
i don't know dude the last thing you
want to do is take any sort of vice
from me when it comes to [__] women
because
the way that i grew up
was basically if somebody didn't like
something you did it even more
um
it was that sort of sadistic mean level
of teasing
and uh for the longest time in my adult
life i didn't know where the line was
um i used to have this
this running joke
where when i was living with robert
kelly way back in the day
he had a similar sadistic upbringing
that was even worse than mine and he was
the only guy that i met that i can
really think of that was further down
that road that i was and basically when
people would sit around
like when we were even at the cellar
when the trashing would start
a lot of times we would pick up
where the game ended would be our
startup no maybe not at the seller
because it got pretty [__] mean but
generally speaking we would like where
we started was the area that most people
didn't even delve in in that game
and that became like the running joke
for a while where people would tease
the two of us
at how we played that game where someone
would make fun of our shirt and then
we'd be like yeah at least my mom isn't
dead like we would take it and we
wouldn't go that far but it was they
would make so i actually had to learn
to dial it back um when it comes to
stuff like that so uh like i said i
wouldn't listen to me
because i am [__] damaged goods
um all right ghost writer oh by the way
i got to uh
i gotta uh
you know i gotta stop you know say
obviously
um the passing of joan rivers
um
i know i talked about this last week but
seriously
without a doubt not even up for debate
she's in the top five all time and i
would actually
if it was in vegas and you you had to
bet
who had written more stand-up material
joan rivers or george carlin um
i i like
i don't know what the spread would be on
that
because i saw her when she did fallon
right
it was this really cool moment where you
know
she was in with johnny carson and then
you know they offered her her own talk
shows a famous [__] story if you
lived under a rock maybe never heard it
but
and she agreed to do the talk show and
she didn't get johnny's blessing
and uh he looked at it like hey i'm
running a hardware store
i'm letting you work here right and then
you open a hardware store across the
street go [__] yourself you're dead to
me and he never talked to her again
um which i can understand being pissed
off but never talking to her again i
mean after he had like a 20-year [__]
friendship was kind of weird
but if you read some of the
autobiographies about his mom and what
the [__] she did to him it all kind of
makes sense
so anyway she had not been on the
tonight show since johnny had it for
whatever reason when leno had it it
never worked out where she got on the
show i don't think jay had anything
against her she just never did the show
so
fallon gets it he brings her in and this
is the first time she'd been on the
tonight show
in like 20 or 25 years and and jimmy
took out a photo of her where she's on
the tonight show with johnny carson it's
johnny carson with like you know
black or brown hair not not even one
gray or white hair on top of his head
and uh
she saw it she goes oh my god she goes
that's my second appearance on the
tonight show that was 1965.
so she basic she did panel
talk show panel for almost half a
century
i mean you're talking about uh
i don't know in the in the the mount
rushmore comedy i think you got to put
her in there
you have to
um
so anyways yeah it's just i remember
when i saw the documentary of her and
she had that [__] card catalog of
like literally a library card catalog
with all these jokes all these different
topics
and to be able to to
last
and be relevant that was another thing
too is she never got like
you know you'll see legendary comics who
just they don't change with the times in
their crowd they keep getting older and
their crowd keeps getting older and i
think what really
um is a benchmark
for you as an artist is if despite you
the fact you keep getting old
um you keep
it's like every new generation it's like
you're surfing and you catch that wave
every [__] time and if you went to go
see her you would see people
from their 20s all the way up to her age
you see that with acts like neil young
there's very few
uh artists that do that and the only
ones who do it are the ones that
continue to i feel continue to grow
um
and they stay current or
you just continue doing what you do and
you what what you do you do it so
[__] well
that it remains undeniable and to me
that's acdc
and they're [__] hilarious about
their
body of work i remember one time
somebody was
gave him a little bit of a dig
in an interview going like you know
you've made the same album
17 times in a row
and then one of them in the band was
like you know what that's [__]
that's [__]
we've done it 18 times in a row and they
all and everybody in the band laughed
and um
you know i mean that might even be
harder than [__] staying relevant is
to do the same sort of thing that long
in a rough but anyway so uh huge huge
huge
[__] huge loss um without a doubt the
real deal so definitely going to miss
joan rivers so anyways with that because
this is a comedy writing thing here
somebody
brought this up ghost writer hello bill
sorry i don't have any funny nickname to
give you
he said i wanted to get your take on
ghost writers for comedians would you
fault any comedian who has a ghost
writer and or are ghost writers a
commonly known part of stand-up comedy
especially for comedians that are well
known slash established thanks and don't
go [__] yourself i like this guy he went
he took a left turn no nickname and he
didn't tell me to go [__] myself
um
let's see uh would i fault any comedian
who has a ghostwriter uh yeah i don't
look at them the same as a comic who
actually wrote all of their own material
absolutely
absolutely um there's people who write
their own material and then they get a
tv or a movie career and they want to
keep going out on the road
um
you know they don't have time to build
up an act
the smart thing to do
is to go out and get a [__] writing
staff and if that works for you that
works for you personally
um i don't look at you
the same way
anymore because to me a comedian
a pure comedian is writing all their own
jokes
and um
you know yeah there's people who do that
they have people that follow them around
and they sit in the back and they write
down things that they say
and uh you know it goes all the way from
uh you know
the comedy version of getting you
getting a little booster chair at the
table
all the way to there carrying you off
the field like [__] kellen winslow
you know it's one of those deals so i
think it all depends on the level
that you do it
um i mean i'm also speaking out of
school here because i've never done that
so i don't know
how much
of the hour ends up being what somebody
else wrote that you then added your own
spin on but uh
you know
i don't think i'm
unique in that i that takes a little uh
a little shine off the apple for me
whatever the [__] expression is if i
find out the person actually has writers
because then i'm sitting there going
well how much
is this your thought or is this somebody
else's thought and that you paid for
so yeah but people definitely have them
and having said all that i don't
necessarily think it's a bad thing to do
it's a smart thing to do because uh
nowadays with the internet how
everything gets made and then nobody
pays for it i mean going out on the road
tap dancing for your [__] lunch i
mean you gotta have an act right
all right advice
uh dear billy bob burr uh needs some
girl advice i recently struck up
conversation with a very attractive
young lady
on the train the other day we talked for
practically the whole
minute train ride i'm 28 but she was
only 20. despite the age difference she
was very cool and we talked about
stand-up comedy and how we are both fans
of you
all right
so what are we talking about here this
is weird way of saying you brought me
into it
get me out of there
when my stop arrived i left without
asking for her number because i didn't
want to be that guy what guy
the guy who finds love the guy who gets
laid
either way you're that guy you were that
guy you were that guy that didn't ask
for a number
so he goes now i'm regretting it she
told me where she works
uh retail and i want to go there and ask
her out so do you think it will come
across creepy or sweet if i just showed
up
for a work unannounced she might not
even be working at the time but i could
leave my number with the co-worker do
not do that
any advice love the podcast go [__]
yourself uh i you know it's not creepy
at all
you're coming in with a raincoat and you
don't want to make eye contact
yeah that's going to be creepy we've
come walking in
and just be like listen it's been it's
been bugging me i don't even remember me
i met you on the bus blah blah blah oh
yeah yeah whatever you say listen it's
been bugging me
from the second i got off the bus that i
didn't ask you for your number i wanted
to ask you for your number but i didn't
want to come off like a creep
uh you know i'd love to take you out
sometime just very simple very honest
all right
don't be all fidgety and awkward you
know just [__] go in there and just
state your case
all right
now if she's not working there don't
stand outside the place you know fogging
up the [__] windows waiting for her
to show up
just come walking in and just say hey is
so-and-so here
no well when does she work again
blah blah
you know all right oh cool all right
thank you whatever who can i say he's
asking ah the creepy guy from the bus
um
whatever yeah i would just go about it
that way but absolutely do that and that
whole [__] thing hey i don't want to
be that guy uh you be that guy
be the guy that asks for what he wants
be respectful of other people but you
got to be the guy
all right or you got to be the lady
either way
um you got to beat that [__] thought
out of your head
you can be so respectful and so like not
wanting to rock the boat that you never
even [__]
you know get what you want in life
all right because life doesn't give a
[__] whether your dreams come true or
not all right
and a lot of the dreams that you have
this isn't one of them but a lot of the
dreams that you have
like i always find it funny that people
pray to a higher power oh please let me
get this job please let me buy and all
that type of [__] the way this whole
[__] world was set up if one person
made it is if basically if you got a
roof over your head and you're eating
every day and you have drinking water
your dream is fulfilled
so to sit there and ask for a corner
office of this person you're really just
clogging up their phone lines
is that nuts
i don't know that's how i look at it all
right all in
dear billy brainfart back in december
2012 i was enlisted in the united states
air force
off we go
into the wild blue yonder flying eye
into the sky
yeah we dive
that's all i know
because that's all they play in the
movies
that's just a credit
[Music]
nothing can stop the us air force how
about a stronger air force
i'll tell you right now they won the
championship they feel like they're
unstoppable and that's the kind of thing
that ends up getting you shot down out
of the sky
you have to feel the weak side pressure
of the third world countries i mean
planes are disappearing who's to say
that these people don't have these
things
all right um despite being engaged
wait a second
i got engaged oh yeah the guy joins the
[__] air force all right he enlisted
i got engaged to what i thought was the
lady of my dreams life was good
unfortunately i got stationed out of
state and had to move despite being
engaged she opted to stay behind in what
was supposed to be temporary we managed
to keep the spark alive for some time
until she lost
the engagement ring in april 2013.
all right let's stop right there
guys are morons
and a man can lose
a [__] ring
all right the only way a woman can lose
a ring is if she's cleaning it near a
sink
okay
and she doesn't understand plumbing and
then later turns on the water and sends
it through the j trap
all right
he's going to feel the weak side
pressure on the j trap on fought down
situations
um
when a woman loses a ring
you gotta understand like this that's
so many of them that's the thing the
ring they get to [__] stick it under
their [__] girlfriend's noses
yeah [__]
yeah
right
they live for that
that's like you getting a game worn
jersey all right so she lost the [__]
engagement ring wow
eventually things spiraled out of
control and she left me in june of 2013
saying i deserved better
all right well
that means either she doesn't love
herself
and uh like when i saying that
you deserve better what i would
immediately think is that if a woman
ever said that to me that it's like all
right you [__] around on me and how
many times
uh anyways this put me in a huge state
of depression to which i credit your
podcast for helping me out thank you
you're welcome
um come to find out she banned oh she
banged four different guys from june to
august there you go and those are just
the ones she admitted to okay that's
like when you come home buzzed or drunk
in high school and your parents go how
many beers have you had how many what do
you say two
if you're really shit-faced you'll say
four and she said four so what does that
mean she had a 12-pack a dick
all right in august she came back into
my life after she said she went
she too went through a depression she
was living even further away now but
still wanted to try and make things work
some type of way
finally february of this year i got the
chance we were waiting on i went house
hunting oh jesus dude what are you doing
where she lived in an attempt to make
things right come to find out she had
been banging a married guy with kids
and also talking to someone else
telling me
wait and also talking to someone else
while telling me she wanted me
i confronted her and she basically said
all i'll ever be to her
is a [__] facetime friend
what you confronted her and she said all
and she said all i'll ever be
to her is a [__] facetime friend
a week ago she called me
and now she wants to be friends again
i love this girl that is your problem
sir
that is the only reason why you're
writing me because everything you're
saying this is a joke your decision
he goes i love this girl very much
despite what she's done to me kind of
like eating sugar
it's good but it [__] you in the long
run my question to you is do i
throw all my chips in this time or do i
fold and yes i'm probably an idiot
either way thanks for the laughs and go
[__] yourself ps do a show in
mississippi already jesus christ bill
that's on my bucket list i'm gonna do
one down there
um all right here's the deal dude
this is the deal
your heart is clouding your brain right
now
all right and uh here's a great
expression
that somebody
said that their therapist told them one
time they said i don't let chaos live in
my life
all right
this is the deal okay um
she has come from some sort of unhealthy
[__] background
where
she feels that yeah she's got some sort
of low self-esteem thing i'm guessing
she just thinks that she's a piece of
[__] and probably doesn't deserve a
great guy like you so she deliberately
went out and sabotaged it probably
because she's used to being around a
bunch of dysfunctional [__] people so
when she actually found somebody
outside of her wheelhouse she ran back
to the
the comfort of that dysfunctional
horseshit all right that is not your
[__] problem
okay when you're trying to find the
person that you're supposed to [__]
be with
you have to find somebody
that is as right as reign all right
that's why you asked the questions are
your parents still together uh what are
your relationships like all the red
flags
both for men and women listen to this
thing okay if they have issues with
their [__] parents and they don't
[__] speak to them
and they have a lot of anger issues
towards their family [__] walk
walk
all right if you're young you're
drafting in the first round okay
okay that's the dez bryant pick like
[__] bill belichick he passed on that
one and everyone's like dude what are
you talking about that's a [__] 10
and look at him
not saying the dude isn't a 10 not
saying he's not a world-class [__]
athlete but all the the baggage that
comes with that horseshit you got to
look at it like that
so
what you need to do is you know all
right you want to compare it to sugar
you want to get over your sugar
addiction just go cold turkey
all right six days [__] in
okay you're gonna start to turn and
you're gonna be looking at candy and
cake and pies going why the [__] would i
ever eat that because it's out of your
system
and that's how you're going to look at
her why the [__] would i ever eat that
yeah
dude that's not the mother of your kids
man you know that right there is a hank
williams song waiting to be written if
you marry her and you have kids with her
all right
i mean dude that that that's the kind of
woman that could turn you into a [__]
alcoholic
uh you need to walk away
all right and you know what you live in
mississippi so you understood that
[__] hank williams reference all
right
walk away and uh and stay single for a
while until you get that craving out of
you because it's not fair for you to get
into another relationship with that [__]
there and you probably want a bill how
do you know all this [__] because i'm a
[__] piece of [__] and i've done it
i've been like all of these all these
questions i've been both people i've
been the person that [__] around i've
been the person that got [__] around
on
i made horrible [__] decisions and
all of that [__] it wasn't until i
finally [__] decided
to uh you know
stop surrounding myself with [__]
people that reminded me of people that i
grew up with
and actually tried to create
a winning culture in the locker room
um so that's what you need to do
you need to uh you need to draft
character first
all right
there's plenty of beautiful women that
came from wonderful families and those
that that's the one that's the keeper
all right
i know what the show okay a woman like
this is [__] your brains out i know
she is okay and that's the sugar right
there okay so you got to let that go
all right
here's the deal next time you you're
thinking about calling her rub one out
i'm dead serious [__] rub one out and
the second you're done i bet as you're
orgasming you're gonna this you're gonna
be like oh
thank god i didn't call her that's
what's gonna happen
all right and remember that thought
all right single for a week
dear billy buzz balls and the lovely
knee if she's available she isn't
unfortunately he goes i am 22 years old
dating a 19 year old girl who goes to
school an hour away
all right uh we've been dating since her
freshman year and we've been able to
maintain a very loving relationship
while maintaining our own independent
lives outside of it jesus what could go
wrong
um
before i decided to get serious with her
i vowed to remind myself that there may
be a point where i have to let her go
considering the drastic changes that go
on and miss
i miss the college years
if it works out with her i will be
immensely happy but if she needs time to
grow then i love her enough to be
content with giving her that time
you're talking like you're her first
serious relationship recently she
expressed her curiosity what it would be
like if she wasn't in a relationship in
college and my mind immediately went to
something that you said on a recent
podcast about the influential dicks that
girls need
to suck in college i said that
um i don't think i said that did i say
that
anyways although you'd be a [__] poet
i knew you were i knew what you were
getting at so we decided that we'd take
a week off and drop the maintenance of a
long-distance one-hour relationship so
she could experience her single self in
college we said no hooking up and she
expressed that her intentions were not
to get with other dudes and i do
actually believe her but you never know
it was more
about handling adversity at school
without me and to uh and to overall take
a break from the long distance
responsibilities like i said although
it's hard i did emotionally prepare
myself knowing that she may eventually
change your mind and need space
i'd like nia's and your opinion on the
idea of uh
of the week break and overall situation
love the podcast and you [__] crushed
it at the chicago oddball show
and it was a privilege to see your your
act uh thanks again and go [__] yourself
well it's funny that's the [__] show
i got [__] about
um
anyways oh and by the way if you find
that blogger do not write a bunch of
negative [__] like [__] you your [__]
[__] because all that does is just feed
into what they're writing okay if you
want to look at it look at it but please
because if i was to meet that person i
would not talk to that person that way
i wouldn't i would listen to what they
were saying i would state my case
and that would be it
um all right
here we go um
i don't think a week is long enough a
long enough time the problem is when you
get into a relationship this series at
that young of age
you know if you've been dating a year
you met him when she was 18 you met her
as a freshman so she went from the first
18 years of her life
of
you know being in the nest with her
parents she's finally out on her own and
then she immediately gets into a
relationship she doesn't know who she is
you know what i mean um
so
and i don't think you can do that in a
week
i don't i don't you know some people can
do it
only need a couple you know some people
you know meet people in college and then
they marry their college sweetheart and
that's it they're fine with it and all
that other people
you know
need to [__] make a bunch of mistakes
through their 20s 30s and into their 40s
all depends
so um i think you guys are gonna have to
figure this out
but um
there is you know that's an amazing time
in your life when you
move out
and it's all of a sudden like hey i can
stay up as late as i want to hey i can
eat whatever i want to i can drink as
much as i want to drink and then you
have to learn how to be a parent to
yourself
to say hey [__] head it's time to go to
bed
don't take this like hey you're driving
don't drink and drive
uh dude you don't have a condom
or if you're a woman he doesn't have a
condom
no
walk away like learning how to walk away
is uh
you know in those dumb situations can i
mean that those are life-altering
[__] moments because horrible
horrible [__] things can happen
uh
in those moments and you need to
i i'm speaking for myself i feel like
you need to to learn those things
and i don't think you can do that in a
week so uh i i would just have a serious
conversation with their about that
you know
and it's hard for me to really give you
tell you exactly what to do because my
whole life experience is superimposed
and informing everything that i'm saying
so i'm not you guys i didn't have your
guys upbringing there's a lot of people
that marry their college sweethearts and
they live happily ever [__] after
and uh and they don't have to go through
all the [__] drama that i went
through
um so
i think you guys need to have a
conversation about it an honest
conversation
and uh
see where the chips fall
and then [__] act on it
um that's it
good luck and god bless america um
anyways that is the uh oh [__] did i
even read the other i could read the
other advertising here and then maybe
tell another quick story
or am i just saying that i have another
quick story to tell you so you'll
actually listen to this [__]
advertising so i won't get [__]
who knows
these and other interesting questions
answered next week on the monday morning
podcast stamps dot com everybody
computers are designed to make running a
business easier including your mailing
and shipping just use stamps.com to get
24 hour access to the post office right
from your own computer no waiting in
line no hassles man stamps dot com makes
mailing and shipping easy just use the
computer and printer you already have to
get official us postage for any letter
any package print the posters directly
onto envelopes labels
um even plain paper
then hand it to your mail carrier
there's no guesswork stamps.com will
send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact
postage you need for any class of mail
you'll never ever have to go to the post
office again personally i use stamps.com
to send out all my posters that i sell
up to some of my shows
i'm a [__] if i can figure out how to
use that scale and calculate the right
price then god damn it so can you right
now use my last name burr burr for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bur burr that stamps.com enter burp
all right legalzoom everybody
when you're planning your for your
future
uh you do financial planning
you get insurance
uh but to get real peace of mind
you know what's funny i thought peace of
mind was spelt
uh
incorrectly peace because of iron maiden
peace of mind and i forgot that that was
a uh
that they spelt it the other way anyways
but to get real peace of mind you got to
make sure your family and finances are
legally protected so where do you turn
for legal help that you can trust only
one place place legalzoom.com for over
13 years they've been helping americans
get personalized wills powers of
attorneys and living trust legalzoom
also helps file
llcs s corporations and more to protect
your you against personal liability
sorry i forgot to make this bigger so i
can see it
all right the company has started was
started by some of the best legal minds
in the country and they make it painless
for you to get the legal protection you
need have questions you can always reach
out to someone at legalzoom and they'll
talk you through the whole process
anyways you can get the legal help
through independent attorneys and
self-help services at your own
discretion but they are not a law firm
for special savings be sure to enter my
code burr burr and the referral block in
the referral box at checkout
go to
legalzoom.com burr to today to protect
your business and take control of your
family's future
all right everybody
that is the monday morning podcast for
this week hey let's let's you want to
hear something funny because i don't
know [__] about football anymore not
like i ever did let's actually look at
some of uh
let's go to nfl.com right now and let's
look at week two and i'm gonna make some
predictions
and this is the thing i have no idea
who won what although i will tell you uh
seattle look [__] unbelievable
and i love that filthy pete carroll
got busted whatever the [__] he was
doing i thought he got busted he just
got busted for he was having him
practice like with pads on or
full contact before he should have dude
that guy
you look i i've never been more wrong
about somebody
than pete carroll
maybe drew bledsoe when we chose tom
brady over drew bledsoe after we won our
first one and we traded him to the
buffalo bills i was like that guy's
going to come back to haunt us i was
wrong it never happened and pete carroll
i was one of those guys going you know
even after he was doing well at usc i
was like dude you know you know he's not
a pro coach you know and i can say that
having never coached a [__] pro and a
[__] pop warner game
um that guy is psychotically driven and
and i i you know
those guys could win it again
if he's gonna [__]
be that much of a maniac
that like he
making that move to me says three days
after the super bowl
his wife was in the other room crying
going are you ever gonna be happy
right he was already
glazing over with x's and o's in front
of his [__] eyes
um i think it's great
that level of commitment although i have
to say the championship ring
that they made for their own fans i mean
it's just i can't the douche chills when
you look at that
oh my god the [__] ball washing and
everybody has bought into how [__]
loud they are
you could take jackson jill jackson jill
jackson phil jack and jill
jackson jacksonville jaguar fans put
them in seattle stadium and they would
be just as loud i challenge every nfl
fan to go to a game there
still stand in that crowd listen to how
loud it is and then turn around and look
at people cheering
just look at him
then add up there like
like [__] it with these craz they're
just cheering
what they owner did was brilliant
because it wasn't illegal
and i think that every other owner is
going to do it around the nfl unless
they do something about that stadium
which what are you going to do about it
it's already [__] built um
that he just was brilliant he's like
contain this [__] noise and reign it
back down on the field
you know i'm not saying they're not
great fans but jesus christ could you
pat yourselves in the back anymore
oh my god i know and i keep doing this
and i get total respect for pete carroll
and your football program up there
obviously a program uh franchise up
there i think you guys i mean i don't
know
it's obviously the little football that
i watched it seems once again
that uh it's a no-brainer that the
the super bowl champion once again is
coming out of the nfc
and uh i'll tell you right now uh if i'm
a football fan i got to be looking to
that first matchup of these seattle
seahawks against those san francisco
49ers
can the 49ers get over the hump i mean
this is the question i mean there's
rumors that jim harbaugh is losing the
locker room
how can you sit and watch that
um anyways
um
all right let's get to let's get to the
week two to schedule for next week let's
see if he can find it
what the [__] schedules all right
standing stats
where the [__] is week two match ups
uh you know what i think this you know
can you make it easy for a [__] old
guy scouting combine draft
playoffs playoffs
team schedule a regular season schedule
right there okay here we go here we go
week two
dude oh the giants played alliance
tonight
in detroit
i have no idea who's going to win that i
don't understand why everybody's
questioning eli manning how many [__]
super bowls does the guy get a win all
of a sudden he doesn't know how to play
the position anymore
[__] new york media that's the
problem when you got 15 papers all in
one town they always got to be
constantly stirring up [__]
not that they don't do it in boston
believe me i know they do um all right
here we go
this is all week one stuff where's week
two
the [__] is it
i don't know bill why don't you just
yell at your computer
texas-sized triumph
this is this is why
this is why i need a [__] assist i
got to do something here because this
should not be this difficult
september 4th through the 9th
complete week 1 schedule where the [__]
is the week 2 schedule your [__]
can i scroll this way
this is bad
this is really this is awful
no is this it right here
no that isn't it all right i'm not going
to torture you guys anymore jesus
[__] christ i i can't you know what
you didn't want to hear my picks anyways
i'll tell you i can tell you what i'll
give you my predictions for week two
week two pregame football analysis
and now off to new england where uh
shockingly last week they lost
decisively
to these miami dolphins of the dolphin
miami county dane wade [__]
area cup
i'll tell you right now i mean what do
you think is going to happen when they
come in and they play the uh the [__]
the [__] austin city isotopes what do
you think is going to happen i'll tell
you right now uh you know i mean i mean
look we all know what tom brady can do
we all know bill belichick is a genius
but i'll tell you right now i mean i
mean
the talent or no talent i mean
you got to be concerned about that
second half i mean they're
lifeless out there it's gonna be a lot
of that [__]
i mean if they lose today they're
they're all in two for the first time
with the brady bell checker
like
they're gonna be doing that
for a [__] hour not for an hour
they'll do it for a little bit and then
they're gonna uh
i don't know what the [__] else they're
gonna talk about i see the world through
my teeth and i know that they're gonna
be doing that [__] or you can just skip
all of that you can go [__] work out
at the gym
right
go for a hike with your [__] dog or
some [__]
and you can come back
the wonderful world of [__] dvr you
can come back an hour before the game
after the game started
you just plow through all the [__]
halftime everything and just get right
to the third
quarter
right let your wife watch the real
housewives
during the first half
you know
and you just make before you go out to
the gym you just say listen sweetheart
you grab a buy a handful of hair the
back of our head you say listen if you
[__] shut off the recording
i swear to god
i'm gonna have you live under the coffee
table no joking
um joking blogger world um anyways
that's the podcast for this week go [__]
yourselves i will talk to you next week
and my prediction tonight is
giants always get off to a slow start a
notorious slow start
these detroit lions of the [__]
greater lion area code have been
gradually improving throughout the years
but do they
takes
i have no idea
for some reason i'm gonna just you know
what
bet against me i'm gonna pick the lions
all right there you go
all right go [__] yourselves oh and
there's the phone
talk to you next week